in die
Da muss ich warten, bis der Sibaro da ist.
Nochmal Leute, wir wollten doch letztens einen Battlefield-Channel.
Hab ich gesagt, den will ich mir im Book marken.
Weil er ziemlich gute Battlefield-Gameplays hatte.
Ich hab vergessen, wie der heißt.
Irgendwas mit S, glaub ich, am Anfang.
Choose my name, 4 Monate, huge big brains up.
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr so sicher, wie hieß der denn.
Doch, doch, ich hab den sogar abonniert auf dem anderen.
Aber ich hab hier mal... Moment, klar.
Ich kann doch einfach auf den zweiten Monitor gucken.
Da bin ich doch bei YouTube eingeloggt.
Ahem, ahem, hm.
Ich soll mal gucken.
Aber die YouTube-Aboliste ist halt auch voll für'n Arsch.
Weil man kann beispielsweise auch nicht sortieren.
Nach wann man abonniert hat und sowas.
Da, hier.
Oder ist das...
War das der?
Ich glaub, der hier war das.
Der hatte ziemlich gute Battlefield-Videos.
Können wir mal eins gucken gleich.
So ein bisschen Battlefield zum Einstieg ist nie verkehrt.
Oh Gott, das erinnert mich an den Ubisoft-Flöter.
Erinnert euch auch noch an den Ubisoft-Flöten, Mann?
Na gut, die Dinger haben Power. Warum sollte da drauf nicht irgendwie...
...ehm, ein N64 ohne PSP und 3DS laufen?
Ich mein, die Dinger haben ja übelst Power.
Ich weiß nicht, was ein Galaxy S20 hat.
8 Kerne oder so mit, was weiß ich, wie viel RAM für'n Smartphone.
Übrigens, das ist ein Trend, der mir nicht gefällt, ne?
Seit Apple jetzt das jetzt auch darauf aufgesprungen ist...
...ist es für immer mehr Hersteller...
Können wir uns ja mal ein Bild von dem Ding angucken.
Finden das immer mehr Hersteller toll...
...so rausstehende Kameras zu machen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da los... Warum?
Ich mein, die übertreiben es hier voll.
Ich mein, wie viel Kameras...
Hat das Ding jetzt 5 Kameras?
Hat das 5 Kameras bzw. 5 Objektive oder was?
Was ist da los?
Oder 4 und ein Blitz oder was?
Man kann es auch übertreiben, ja.
Das sieht mega Woodface aus, da hast du recht.
Was kosten so ein Kram eigentlich?
Wie sind denn bei Samsung eigentlich so die Updates?
Ich hatte noch nie ein Samsung-Smartphone.
Wie lang supporten die das mit offiziellen Android-Updates...
...und wie lang...
...und wie beliebt ist das Ganze für Custom-Roms?
Falls die das nicht mehr supporten.
Kennen sich da jemanden mit aus?
Aber ich finde diese Kamera-Geschichte, die jetzt mehr und mehr...
...Smartphone-Hersteller machen...
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Das sieht doch scheiße aus.
Und mal davon abgesehen, mir geht es gar nicht mal so sehr ums Aussehen.
Erstens, es ist cool, wenn man eine halbwegs gute Kamera dabei hat.
Keine Frage.
Aber ich brauchte jetzt keine ultra-krasse Kamera mit Slow-Mo-Effekten...
...und zig HDR und sonst was Ding an.
Bei einem Smartphone, wo ich einfach mal meine Katze fotografiere.
Und ich finde es halt auch sehr unhandlich, wenn man das Ding mal angenommen...
...und man legt das auf den Tisch, dann wackelt es.
Das wackelt einfach, wenn man es auf den Tisch legt.
Und man legt es dann natürlich mit der Seite nach unten auf den Tisch.
Weil oben liegt ja das Display, ne?
Das Einzige, was man dann machen kann, ist, man macht halt eine Hülle drum...
...die dann halt quasi wieder das hier auffüllt, wo man halt komplett in Frage stellt...
...warum man nicht das Ding an sich dicker bzw. dünner macht.
Naja.
Aber es machen immer mehr Hersteller so komische Dinger mit den Kameras...
...und ich finde, das ist irgendwie nicht so das, was mir gefällt.
Ich meine, wenn man sich das alte...
Keine Ahnung, was ich mal hier so ein iPhone...
Was habe ich noch mal für ein iPhone?
Also, hätte ich mir das selbst kaufen müssen, dann wüsste ich es.
Ja, aber ich habe das ja von der Firma gekriegt.
Was hatte ich noch mal in L...
Ne.
XE?
Ne, XR?
XR, glaube ich, ja.
So, und da geht das noch.
Da geht das noch.
Wobei, da steht der Kram auch schon ein bisschen raus.
Das nervt mich bei dem Ding schon.
Gibt es eigentlich Neuigkeiten zum neuen iPhone SE?
Oder SE2 oder so?
Gibt es da schon was Neues?
Oh, ich meine, die Musik ist ein bisschen laut.
Ne, ist noch nichts, ne?
Gibt zwar nichts.
Weil da bin ich mal gespannt.
Auf das Ding bin ich mal gespannt.
Was die da machen.
Ok, aktuell läuft das Stream noch gut.
Moin, Serum 98.
Schauen habe ich irgendwelche.
Was die heftigste Kamera hat das Nokia...
Mit TF ist jetzt gerade eine Taube gegen mein Fenster geflogen.
Jetzt ist sie wieder weg.
Ich muss mal kurz aus dem Fenster gucken, ob die jetzt auf der Straße liegt oder so.
Ich sehe nichts.
Scheint hat sie überlebt.
Streamsniper, genau.
Richtig MonkaS.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade nachgucken?
Ja, es gibt ja Gerüchte, dass das SE2 quasi ein iPhone 6 ist.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das dann von der Größe her gut ist.
Also ich habe ja kein iPhone SE, aber ich habe meiner Mutter damals ein iPhone SE gekauft.
Vor einem Jahr oder so.
Weil die ist noch mit so einem Ollen, Siemens Club Handy rumgelaufen.
Das kann ja nicht sein, damit kann sie ja nichts machen.
Was hat irgendjemand gerade gesagt, was die größte Kamerabeule hat?
Nokia, da gibt es sie überhaupt noch.
Nokia 808 Pure View.
What the fuck, Alter.
Das sieht aus wie ein Taser.
Das sieht eher aus wie ein Taser als wie ein Smartphone.
Was ist mit Nokia los?
Ich weiß nicht, ob da die Welt wirklich drauf gewartet hat.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, es hat sich nicht verkauft, gut.
Es ist auch voll unhandlich.
Ohje, Leute.
Ist das hinten eine Tastatur zum Ausklappen oder was ist das?
Was kostet der Kram?
Oh, das ist eine Tastatur.
Oh, das ist ein neues jetzt hier, guck mal.
Das hat jetzt so ein Half-Life-Drohnen-Auge.
Aber es sieht echt aus wie ein Taser.
Und wenn du das einem in den Kopf schmeißt, das tut auch auf jeden Fall weh.
Aber hübsch ist es nicht.
Hübsch ist es echt nicht.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So, von wann ist das?
Von?
Ach, von 2012, okay.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
2012, da waren sie noch nicht so gut, den Kram klein zu bauen.
Und da wollte Nokia halt eine Kamera.
Im Prinzip hat Nokia eine Kamera reingebaut.
Und hat halt da irgendwie so eine Handyhülle drum geschlaucht.
Sieht echt aus wie ein übergroßer Schrumpfschlauch, den sie da drum gemacht haben.
Sieht wirklich hässlich aus.
Übrigens, ich muss mein Fragentool wieder anmachen.
Sonst übersehe ich das Ganze.
Was?
Wer walt's weh abonniert?
Sechs Monate, big brain, huge sub.
Ich muss mein, nachdem ich es ja gestern wieder gefunden habe,
ich muss mein Fragenaufzeichnungstool anschmeißen, weil sonst vergesse ich manche Sachen.
Habe ich hier so viel olle Linux-Sachen noch am Start?
Ja,.net huge.
Gut, dass ich das net 3 genannt habe.
Irgendjemand hat gerade gefragt, inwiefern betrifft dich eigentlich die Corona-Krise?
Ja, das betrifft mich.
Ja, so wie es jeden auch betrifft.
Du musst dir halt Gedanken machen, wenn du rausgehst und größere Menschenansammlungen hast,
ob du dir nicht den Scheiß anfällst.
Inwieweit es mich betrifft, ist, dass ich mich permanent aufrege,
wenn ich draußen immer unterwegs bin, über Leute, die bescheuert sind.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja letztens erzählt, der Familienausflug mit 15 Leuten,
die 20 Leute auf der Decke beim Picknick, letztens in der Kneipe 10 Leute beim Saufen gewesen.
Ich dachte, was ist mit euch los?
Das betrifft mich, ich muss mich noch mehr über andere Leute aufregen.
Wenn du dich auf deine Mitmenschen verlassen musst, dann bist du echt verlassen.
Sag mal, kann ich den Kram nicht sogar aufmachen?
Und hier ist das Pepega-Board.
Das Pepega-Board ist aber kaputt, wie es aussieht.
Ich starte das jetzt nochmal neu.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob das Pepega-Board wieder funktioniert.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob das Pepega-Board auch auf meinem anderen Rechner funktioniert.
Was muss ich? Port 5000?
Ah, guck mal, ich habe sogar eingestellt, dass man vom anderen Rechner drauf zugreifen kann.
Excellent.
Gut, inwieweit betrifft mich Corona sonst noch?
Ich bin zum Zwangshomeoffice verordnet.
Was ich witzig fand, ich habe am Tag vorher noch ein bisschen rumgemeckert.
Ich habe auch einen Brief auf die Arbeit geschrieben und gesagt,
wie ganz Deutschland ist in Aufregung und man hört bei euch überhaupt nichts.
Und ein paar Informationen wären nicht schlecht.
Und lustigerweise kam direkt danach, kam am Tag danach, da musste ich natürlich nochmal auf die Arbeit fahren.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgeflammt auf Twitter.
Da wollte ich gar nicht in den Zug setzen.
Da hatte ich das Kram konzentriert.
Wir haben ja Microsoft, wir haben ja Teams auf der Arbeit, weil mittlerweile Teams ja voll angesagt ist.
Also auf dem aufsteigenden Ast.
Ich meine, die meisten haben noch Slack, aber Teams, ich glaube Teams sogar aktuell kostenlos.
Da habe ich eine Mail bekommen, da war ich gerade auf dem Weg mittags zum Südbahnhof.
Ich war gerade auf dem Weg zum Südbahnhof und da habe ich eine Einladung gekriegt.
Also ich haue ja immer 15.30 Uhr ab und da habe ich eine Einladung gekriegt,
als ich unterwegs war, irgendwie keine Ahnung, 15.30 Uhr, 15.40 Uhr oder so.
Da habe ich auf einmal auf meinem Handy, auf dem Smartphone eine Einladung aufgeploppt von meinem Chef.
16 Uhr bis 16.30 Uhr neue Corona-Infos.
So und dann habe ich, also sowas von agil, so agil ist man ja selten.
So Agile ist man ja selten.
Und dann habe ich am Südbahnhof und während ich im Zug gesessen habe, Microsoft Teams konferenzt.
Ne, ich habe auf der Heimfahrt, auf der Heimfahrt habe ich im Teams Call gehockt.
Und ich muss sagen, bis auf ein paar Unterbrechungen, weil halt auf der Strecke und Deutschland überhaupt Mobilfunkausbau
und generell Deutschland Infrastrukturausbau nicht so der Wahnsinn ist, ging das erstaunlich gut.
Ich hatte ein paar Unterbrechungen drinnen, aber ich habe alles soweit mitgekriegt.
Und das erste, was mein Chef gesagt hat, war, wir dürfen nicht mehr, ich meine letztendlich verbieten,
sie sind ja nicht die Polizei, sie können sich das ja nicht verbieten, aber sie haben gesagt,
sie wollen nicht mehr, dass Leute, die mit dem Zug fahren, also dass Leute nicht mehr mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln auf die Arbeit kommen.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja gut.
Und dann nicht.
Und jetzt habe ich Homeoffice.
Auf unbestimmte Zeit.
Warum bist du eigentlich so agil und dynamisch?
Ich habe genug BWL-Talks mittlerweile auf YouTube geguckt, das schlägt über.
Und kannst du bitte nochmal die Corona-Ul zeigen?
Corona-Stats online und dann musst du Source 2 dran machen, das ist nämlich aktueller.
Und jetzt aktuell sehen wir, wir haben 22.000 New Cases, es gibt gerade keine Report.
Aber es ist ja auch Wochenende, da arbeitet das Institut wahrscheinlich nicht da oder das Ding.
Aber das ist halbwegs aktuell.
Was ist dein Eindruck von Usability von Teams?
Also, wir hatten davor auf der Arbeit eine Mischung aus, also ich zähle mal alles auf,
was so ein bisschen in Hand in Hand spielt.
Wir haben als Ticketsystem Jira, was die coolen Leute Jira oder Gyra oder so aussprechen.
Das heißt aber Jira.
Als Ticketsystem, wir haben ganz normales Outlook-Exchange-Gedöns für E-Mail und Termine und sowas.
Und bisher hatten wir als Collaboration, Messaging, was auch immer, Plattform.
Skype for Business.
Und ganz ehrlich, im Vergleich zu Skype for Business ist Teams der pure Luxus.
Ich meine Teams scheißt voll ab im Vergleich zu Discord, finde ich.
Und ich verstehe ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe nicht, warum so wenige Enterprise-Business-Leute Discord in Erwägung ziehen.
Weil, ich kann euch auch sagen warum.
Bei Skype und so habe ich dann irgendwie noch verstanden, das konnte man selbst hosten.
Also sprich, wenn man jetzt sagt, man möchte auf gar keinen Fall, dass man was in der Cloud laufen hat,
was nicht unter seiner Hoheit ist, dann verwendet man was bei sich gehostet.
Das kann ich verstehen, ja.
Aber wenn man jetzt die Auswahl hat zwischen Cloud und Cloud,
dann kann man auch was richtig Gutes nehmen mit Discord.
Aber Discord hängt halt dieses Gaming-Gedöns an.
Keine AD-Authentifizierung.
Ach, da könnte man mit Sicherheit irgendwas machen.
Und selbst wenn nicht, ist doch auch egal, auch z.B. ein Discord-Account.
Da gäbe es bestimmt Möglichkeiten, wenn es die entsprechende Nachfrage gibt.
Ansonsten muss ich sagen, im Vergleich zu Skype for Business ist Microsoft Teams echt Erholung pur.
Eine Sache, die cool ist, die haben einen eingebauten Meme-Creator,
wo ich mich frage, wann sie das bei uns abschalten, weil wir haben ja Leute, die haben, was sowas angeht, keinen Humor.
Und eine Sache, die mir bei Teams fehlt, ist...
Supergeile Screenshot, 50 Millimeter.
Was mir bei Teams fehlt, ist, auch wenn man es hier sieht, eine ordentliche Kalenderintegration,
weil das gibt es bei uns schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Das gibt es, glaube ich, nur, wenn man Exchange und Gedöns auch in der Cloud verwendet.
Machen wir nicht.
Dementsprechend gibt es keine ordentliche Kalenderintegration.
Das heißt, wenn ich einen Termin habe und ich möchte in Teams in diesem Termin joinen,
dann muss ich immer erst in mein Outlook den Link anklicken.
Und nachdem ich kein Outlook habe, bei mir lokal, was in das Firma-Outlook kann,
muss ich immer über meinen Remote-Desktop dort das Outlook aufmachen und den Link rauskopieren
und dann mal mir lokal im Browser, dass es dann aufgeht, Teams.
Das ist wir.
Was man auch machen kann, ist, dann im Remote-Desktop eine Chat-Message schreiben,
in den jeweiligen Besprechungs-Chatroom, dann taucht es auch im Web-Interface von Teams auf.
Das ist ein bisschen wir.
Also die Kalenderintegration sackt, so wie es jetzt zumindest bei uns ist.
Und ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil wir dann selbst Gehorchstundes Exchange haben.
Aber das ist ein bisschen doof.
Und eine Sache, die mir auch wirklich extrem fehlt, sind, und ich weiß, es klingt jetzt doof,
weil Business und so, sind Twitch-Emails.
Ich erwische mich so oft bei, dass ich irgendwie sowas schreibe,
wie irgendwie, ist das wieder kaputt, keck weh.
So, und dann stelle ich in dem Moment fest, ah fuck, keck weh geht ja nicht.
Habt ihr vor, in die Cloud zu gehen mit Exchange?
Na, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Nachdem bei uns ja alle gerade, alle alles in die Cloud packen wollen,
wird wahrscheinlich Exchange auch irgendwann mal in die Cloud gehen, ja.
Naja, das fehlt mir, das fehlt mir bei Teams so ein bisschen.
Sollen wir mal gucken, ob ich Fragen, Fragen überlesen hab.
Das war von gestern, das können wir wegmachen.
Hast du dir schon ein Klopapier Vorrat angeschafft?
Ich hab mir bei einem Großhändler 96 Rollen bestellt.
96 Rollen war einfach das kleinste, was es gab.
Und da haben sich die Leute auf Twitter schon wieder aufgeregt, wie ich das wagen kann.
96 Rollen Klopapier zu bestellen.
Da waren sie angepisst teilweise.
Wie kannst du es nur wagen, 96 Rollen zu bestellen.
Meine Güte, Max.
Kifken abonniert, sieben Monate, nice, dankeschön.
Michael, da geb ich dir teilweise recht.
Ich hab ja auch schon auf Twitter gepostet, weil sie da geschrieben haben,
Stay Home, Stay Home Challenge, zu Hause bleiben.
Wen interessiert das eigentlich, so als echter Hacker-Man?
Wir haben übrigens den Hacker-Man als neues Emote, falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt.
So den echten Hacker-Man interessiert das ähnlich, der bleibt eh standardmäßig daheim.
Genau, EVOT.
Atlassian Gyra.
So sprechen es die coolen Leute aus.
Wobei die sagen ja selbst, es heißt nicht Gyra, es heißt Hierer.
Aber was juckt uns da schon, was der Hersteller sagt.
Der Qui sagt, Teams ist halt ein typisches Microsoft Produkt, ich finde es überladen und unübersichtlich.
Ja, es hat viele merkwürdige Sachen, da geb ich dir recht.
Für mich wäre das Lieblingstool, was wir benutzen könnten, Discord.
Machs super, wir wirst das Virus hacken.
Wir haben es uns gestern im Stream angeschaut, ich kann mich da immer nicht motivieren.
Außerdem muss ich heute Battlefield Top Clips Video aufnehmen.
Makes no sense, DotA, drei Monate, huge brain, big brain sub, Dankeschön.
Deckerman ist im Stimmstand.
Bookmark? Warum?
Okay, gut, haben wir beantwortet alles.
Gucken wir mal, was haben wir denn für Videos, ich hab noch die von letztem Mal, die wir noch nicht geguckt haben, auf.
Und, ähm, noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Das hab ich gerade gefunden, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Windows Steller machen, das ist bestimmt so ein Scam Mars Video.
Ich guck mir immer gerne solche Videos an, einfach weil ich mich da immer kaputt lachen muss, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Aber als erstes, will ich mir mal hier Dings angucken.
Ich hab grad gesehen, das Doom Eternal Review von der GameStar.
Weil ich hab voll verdrängt, dass da Kram rauskommt.
Ihr nutzt Telegram.
Mal angucken, wie das geworden ist.
Ah, Dimitri.
Gibt es einen Grund, warum du Chromium am liebsten benutzt?
Ja, weil ich am liebsten eigentlich an sich Chrom verwende. Aber, also die ursprüngliche Sache, kann ich jetzt mal erzählen, warum ich Chromium verwende ist, weil Chrom mich immer nervt mit Chromecast.
Also sprich, wenn es ein Chromecast Device im Netzwerk erkennt, dann schlägt es einem immer vor, hier mache, mach hier Chromecast und hier.
Und ich hab keinen Bock aus Versehen Videos, ähm, wo ich nicht unbedingt will, dass die jeder sieht.
Ihr könnt euch jetzt jeder überlegen, was das ist oder was es nicht ist, hat jeder so seins, dass ich die aus Versehen auf den Fernseher broadcaste.
Das war so die ursprüngliche Variante, warum ich mal Chromium angefangen hab.
Und mittlerweile finde ich es eigentlich insofern ganz praktisch, dass ich noch einen zweiten Chrome Browser hab mit einem unterschiedlichen Profil, ähm, zum ausprobieren.
Aber Chrome basierte Browser gibt es ja mittlerweile wie Sand am Meer, gibt es ja genug.
Brave ist zur Zeit wohl sehr beliebt und auch stark in der Verbreitung nimmt dazu.
Jetzt der neue Edge ist auch Chrome basiert, Vivaldi haben wir auch noch drauf.
Ich hab hier, ich hab hier glaube ich acht Browser installiert oder so.
Dann ist Doom Eternal der Premium Champagner.
Der Shooter veredelt so ziemlich alles, was 2016 schon zur obersten Güteklasse gehörte.
Die Kämpfe laufen in puncto Intensität jedem anderen Shooter den Rang ab.
Die Kampagne inszeniert sich noch hochwertiger und abwechslungsreicher und völlig überraschend fasziniert sogar die Story des neuen Doom.
Was, die Story?
Story?
Der Doom 2016 hatte ja nicht wirklich ne Story.
Also sie hatten ne Story, aber die Story war halt für n Arsch.
Vor 20 Jahren gesagt, doch für all diese Exzellenz zahlt Doom Eternal auch einen Preis.
Ich frag mich, ob sie wieder 50 unnötige Skilltrees hatten.
Die Video ein bisschen lauter, okay.
Weil, was ich im letzten Doom sehr merkwürdig fand ist, du hattest ja zig Skilltrees.
Du hattest irgendwelche Runen zum unlocken.
Du hattest Waffen, die du aufleveln kannst.
Du konntest glaube ich den Anzug irgendwie leveln.
Also ganz, du hattest ganz viele nicht miteinander verbundene Skilltrees, so komisch.
Bei der Story müssen wir natürlich einhaken.
Natürlich passt die simple Prämisse von Doom Eternal in Gänze auf ne einzige Patronenhülse.
Als Doom Slayer steuert ihr die demonenverseuchte Erde an, mit dem greifbaren Ziel alles umzubringen, was Hörnchen hat.
Die knapp 15-stündige Singleplayer-Kampagne führt euch mit jedem Level in eine gänzlich neue Umgebung.
Die Mission bleibt jedoch immer die gleiche.
Ballern, ballern, springen und ballern.
Ja, ich glaub das ist das, was die Leute haben wollen.
Ich gehöre hierher.
Oh, deutsches Voice-Eig-Ding.
Vielleicht ist es gar nicht schlecht.
Ich muss sagen, die deutsche Variante, zumindest Geralt in Witcher 3 fand ich auf Deutsch gut.
Die war echt nicht übel.
Rest drum herum, die NPCs waren teilweise nicht so gut, aber Geralt war gut.
Nur Dooms aus den 90ern.
Der ganze Mythos um den Doom Slayer bekommt dadurch wunderbar viel Fleisch auf die Rippen.
Die Umgebungen strotzen nur so vor Details.
Die Parallele zu Dark Souls bedeutet allerdings auch, dass ihr die Datenbank-Einträge selbstständig studieren müsst, um die Lore so wirklich zu verstehen.
Die Lore geht mir sowas von vorbei.
Ich dürfte bereits im ersten Level den Faden verlieren, wer hier jetzt warum was genau will.
Aber hey, es ist Doom, die Lore funktioniert als spannende Ergänzung.
Doom Eternal macht aber auch ohne sie unheimlich viel Spaß.
Ironischerweise beginnt Doom Eternal aber ziemlich langweilig.
Das erste Level auf der Erde konfrontiert uns mit Kanonenfuttergegnern, kann lange nicht mit der Intensität und vor allem Atmosphäre von 2016 mithalten.
Die Areale wirken leblos, Feinde bloß irgendwie in der Landschaft platziert.
Aber bei Beelzebubsbad, das ändert sich drastisch.
Das ist so eine typische Game-Star-Redewendung, wo ich mich immer frage, müssen das die Leute von der Game-Star bringen, weil es die Game-Star ist?
Solche Sachen hier.
Und vor allem Atmosphäre von Doom 2016 mithalten.
Die Areale wirken leblos, Feinde bloß irgendwie in der Landschaft platziert.
Aber bei Beelzebubsbad, das ändert sich drastisch.
What the fuck? Warum müssen die sowas sagen, weil es die Game-Star ist?
Bei Beelzebubsbad? Ich fand's noch geil, wo sie dann auch immer...
Wo sie bei Diablo 3 auch irgendwas geschrieben haben.
Die wilde Monster hat's ist wieder da.
Doobie day, 6 Monate, wupp wupp, huge sub.
Ups, falsche Emote gedrückt.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Sobald ihr ein paar neue Waffen und Gegnertypen begegnet, wird jeder neue Kampf zu einem Hardstyle genervt.
Max, da kommt ein neues Video. Heute nehme ich auf.
Riesige Hell Knights prügeln uns aus der Arena.
Oder lassen sich nur aus mittlerer Distanz besiegen.
Fliegende Cacodemons spucken giftigen Schleim.
Zwar finden nur wenige wirklich neue Monster ihren Wege die Arena, doch die haben es dafür in sich.
Die Anachnotronen-Spinne aus Doom 64 feuert beispielsweise unheimlich präzise aus der Distanz.
Zerstören wir ihr Geschütz, wechselt sie flugs in den Nahkampfmodus und behakt uns mit Klauen und Kurz-Distanz-Artillerie-Projektilen.
Kurz-Distanz-Artillerie-Projektilen? Big-Brain-Satz.
Das Schwierigkeitsgrade reicht eine einzige Sekunde des Stillstandes und ihr werdet zu Hackfleisch verarbeitet.
Jeder der Gegnertypen beherrscht eigene Angriffe, erfordert separate Strategien und zwingt uns in einem irrsinnigen Tempo...
Spiel... ist das Controller-Gameplay?
Die Faszination dieser Mischung aus Waffen und Gegnervielfalt funktionierte schon in Doom 2016, doch Eternal fährt einige spannende Neuerungen auf.
Die Einschläge unserer Geschosse hinterlassen beispielsweise jetzt detaillierte Spuren auf unseren Feinden.
Einem Hell-Night reicht es die Muskeln vom Torso, der Kakodin mit verlierten Teilen des Kopfes.
Das sorgt für ein sehr wuchtiges Treffergefühl der Union schon sehr wuchtigen Waffen.
Außerdem haben Feindlichkeits-Schwachstellen, die wir ausschalten können.
Klingt nach wenig, aber einer Riesenspinne das Geschütz wegzuballern fühlt sich.
Und auch am Bonus ist überlebensnotwendig.
Zwar gibt es de facto eine reguläre Waffe weniger, nämlich die Pistole.
Das muss man sagen, das hat sich die letzten Jahre wirklich gebessert.
Es juckt heute keinem mehr, ob Spiele quasi Gewalt darstellen.
Es wird kaum noch irgendwas indiziert.
Das Einzige, was halt indiziert wird oder was halt angepasst werden muss, wenn es in Game...
Wenn es Hakenkreuze in Wolfenstein und sowas gibt, da sind sie empfindlich logischerweise.
Aber Gewalt in Videospielen juckt nicht mehr so wirklich.
Trotzdem erweitert.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran, dass einfach das Umfeld sich geändert hat.
Dass einfach auch viele Alte weg sind.
Wer vor einem Schrotelten greift Haken und anderen Gadgets, wird der Kampf so vielfältig wie nie.
Jede neue Waffe, jeder neue Aufsatz spielt sich großartig.
Und auch an der Superwaffenfront hat sich was getan, aber das spoilern wir hier nicht.
Die Sprungakrobatiken sind auch außerhalb der Kämpfe wichtiger.
Man kann jetzt irgendwie an der Wand klettern.
Man kann doch jetzt irgendwie an der Wand klettern, habe ich in einem Briefview gesehen.
Die Sprungeinlagen lockern die Schießereien zwar auf, begeistern allerdings sehr, sehr selten.
Um langfristig zu motivieren, gibt es in Doom Eternal außerdem haufenweise Upgradespiralen.
Im Rahmen der Kampagne verbessert ihr eure Waffen, euren Anzug.
Das ging mir in Doom 2016 schon auf den Kick, dass es irgendwie vier, fünf unabhängige Skilltrees gab.
Oh, zehn Minuten, eine Sekunde für mehr Ads.
Da gibt es immer irgendwas, das ihr hochrüsten könnt.
Da kann man jetzt natürlich einwerfen, dass das auf dem Papier nicht nach super vielen Neuerungen klingt.
Doch wie auch der Edel-Champagner vielleicht von außen kaum anders aussieht als der Aldi-Sect,
zählt letztlich der Geschmack der Mixtur.
Und Eternal schmeckt sehr viel intensiver als Doom 2016.
Durch den Wegfall der Pistole mit unendlich Munition gibt es kein Auffangnetz mehr.
Wenn der Ammo-Klips durchrattert, steht ohne Fernkampfwaffe da und das passiert fast in jedem Kampf.
Hier müsst ihr mit Köpfchen kontern und das sieht dann so aus.
Hier sieht man ganz schön, wie wir permanent und irrsinnig schnell denken müssen.
Wenn die Muni alle geht, müsst ihr mit Kettenwege neue Ammo aus den Gegnern aussägen.
Also wenn man da wirklich viel denken müsste, wäre das Spiel für 90% der Leute schon mal nicht das Richtige.
Ihr braucht den Flammenwerfer einsetzen, für mehr Leben braucht ihr Glory-Kills
und die Schwachstellen der Feinde müsst ihr ebenfalls mit den richtigen Waffen wegholzen,
um es euch leichter zu machen.
Doom fordert ununterbrochen Strategie und Geschick.
Damn.
Heiß.
Also ich meine, das Treffer-Feelback sieht aber schon im Video geil aus.
Den kompletten Verlust unserer Munition im Gegenzug, die Vorteile der neuen Flammen- und Eiswerfer.
Gegner attackieren uns in weitgrösseren Abzahlen.
Hey, ich spiele das nicht im Stream, das ist jetzt langweilig zu gucken.
... unter den neuen Schwachstellen und und und.
Jeder Kampf fordert ein rasantes Durchwechseln von knarren Manövern und Fähigkeiten.
Doom 2016 war ein Skatepark der Gewalt.
Doom Eternal ist Surfen im Tsunami.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Controller.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Controller Gameplay.
Eternal bietet übrigens auch einen asymmetrischen Multiplayer-Modus,
in dem zwei Dämonen gegen einen Doom-Slayer antreten.
Alle verkörpert von echten Menschen.
Der Multiplayer im letzten war richtig schlecht.
Im Testzeitraum war der PvP-Modus noch nicht online.
Wir behalten uns deshalb vor, Eternal aufzuwerten, sollte der Multiplayer...
Wisst ihr, was ich doof finde?
Ich glaube nämlich, dass dieser Multiplayer nach einem Monat kein Mensch mehr spielt.
Was ich mich frage ist...
Warum braucht zwingend jedes Game mittlerweile einen Multiplayer?
Und zu?
Ich meine, wenn es ein Spiel ist, wo man sagt, wir setzen voll auf Singleplayer,
ist doch in Ordnung.
Scheiß drauf.
Das fand ich jetzt...
Da sieht man mal, wie Geschmäcker verschieden sind.
Ich fand das in Doom 2016 nervig.
Dass ab der zweiten Hälfte in dem Spiel alles dunkel, der Monenwelt, blutig, düster, sonst wie war.
Das ist wie, wenn man versucht hat...
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar ein Video gesehen.
Wie wenn man versucht hätte, wie sie es in Dead Space gemacht haben,
quasi immer das Gleiche, immer wieder aufzulegen, aber halt nicht richtig.
Mein Dead Space war im Prinzip auch von Anfang bis Ende
mehr oder weniger immer das Gleiche von den Levels her.
Und trotzdem, also von der Umgebung her, und trotzdem haben sie es ganz gut hingekriegt.
Und ich finde, das haben sie bei Doom 2016 nicht hingekriegt.
Das war ab der zweiten Hälfte nur noch dunkel und der Mondensäug.
Und das fand ich gar nicht so gut.
Wenn es ein bisschen abwechslungsreicher ist, hätte ich nix dagegen.
...durch die herausgestellten Jump-and-Run-Passagen, die bunteren Power-Ups und offenen Areale
sehr viel mehr nach Arcade-Videospiel an.
Keine Frage, auch Doom 2016 ist ein Arcade-Shooter...
Mit Singleplayer-Games kann ich persönlich nichts anfangen, sagt Lukizu.
Naja, wenn du mit dem Game nichts anfangen kannst, ist ja vollkommen legitim.
Ich glaube aber kaum, dass ein Spiel, was quasi 90% Singleplayer ist
und 10% halbherzige Multiplayer hat, dich auf einmal anspricht.
Wenn man halt keine Singleplayer-Spiele mag, dann...
Es gibt ja auch genug Spiele, wo ich jetzt sage, hier, das ist überhaupt nicht meins.
Das heißt nicht, dass das Spiel schlecht ist oder so.
Aber das sind halt Spiele, die sind halt nicht meins.
Ich muss ja nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig jedes Game jedem gefallen.
...verkauft sich allerdings eher als ein selbstironisches Dead Space
und weniger als Serious Sam.
Eternal gibt sich hier...
Neues Serious Sam soll ja auch kommen, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Was Serious Sam muss ich wissen...
Wisst ihr an was ich immer denken muss bei Serious Sam?
...
Wer das gespielt hat, weiß, was ich meine.
Ja, wo ich immer bei Serious Sam dran denke.
Genau, die Typen mit den Bomben.
...
Genau, die Typen.
Und da hast du in Serious Sam ja Massen abbekommen.
...
Das größte Problem im Vergleich zu Doom 2016 ist aber der Spannungsverlauf.
Wo der Vorgänger ab der ersten Mission die Nackenhaare nach oben trieb,
klar, das war ja auch damals alles noch neu, bricht Eternal mit allen gängigen Mainstream Marotten,
indem es in Mid- und Late-Game mit Abstand am besten ist.
Der Einstieg fühlt sich behäbig an, die ersten drei Level spielen sich eher trocken,
weil ohne Waffen- und Gegnervielfalt auch die taktische Tiefe fehlt.
Doch danach geht es Level für Level ab wie Schmitz Katze oder Doomgeist Daisy.
Erst in den letzten zwei Missionen geht dem Spiel wieder die Puste aus,
weil man alles gesehen und längst alles freigeschaltet hat und es in den Kämpfen nicht wirklich mehr viel neu zu leben gibt.
Ja, dieses Rumgeklettere, da war ich ja am Anfang auch skeptisch,
ob das gut zu dem Game passt, aber wenn die Levels gut aufgebaut sind, ist doch top.
Und es ist sogar eher ein Vorteil, dass er das gar nicht erwähnt, weil wenn er das gar nicht erwähnt,
heißt für mich, das passt einfach gut ins Gameplay, sodass man das überhaupt nicht in Frage stellt.
Das ist eigentlich das Beste, was passieren kann.
Beide Schwächen sind aber bloß Stolpersteinchen in einem ansonsten astreinen Shooter-Erlebnis.
Doom Eternal spielt sich hervorragend, es sieht technisch fantastisch aus,
lief auf unseren Testsystemen butterweich, das Art-Design frischt jede Mission mit neuen Ideen auf
und der Soundtrack von Nick Gordon gehört zum Besten, was die Gaelic Orange zu bieten hat.
Headbangers! Gibt's das für alle Plattformen?
Naja, auf jeden Fall PC, Xbox und Playstation.
Switch eher nicht.
Doom Eternal setzt an allen Stärken von Doom...
Stadia? Keine Ahnung. Ja, ich glaube Stadia gibt's wahrscheinlich auch.
Die bisher vage Hintergrundgeschichte wird zum heimlichen Star des Spiels.
Sequels lassen sich dank besserer Map-Funktion leichter finden.
Also dass das mal jemand in einem Doom-Review sagt, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Die Geschichte wird zum heimlichen Star, also das hätte ich mit allerletztens in einem Doom erwartet.
Technik vermischt sich mit Level-Design-Abwechslung.
Die Kämpfe spielen sich taktischer, aber auch fordernder und mit mehr Möglichkeiten,
also Schwachstellen, neue Waffen und Modi, wachsen auch die Gefahren.
Feine greifen härter und zahlreicher an und ihr könnt anders als früher all eure Money verlieren.
Und wieso ist das so? Naja, weil es in Doom Eternal keine Pistole mehr gibt.
Kommt auch auf der Switch. Okay, wundert mich ehrlich gesagt nur zum Teil,
weil das letzte haben sie ja auch wohl recht brauchbar auf die Switch portiert.
Also dann, X-Marcel, sieben Monate, huge sub.
Ich bin echt froh, dass ich mein Fragenaufzeichnungstool wieder gefunden habe,
weil jetzt übersehe ich nichts.
Was?
Ja, warum nicht, so kann man auch die Leute loggen.
Oh, jetzt geht's ab hier, Prime1996 und Eliko36TwitchPrimePoggers.
Der Chat-IQ steigt wieder ins unermessliche.
Was denkst du eigentlich über sowas wie Stadia?
Nur kurz, weil da hab ich mich schon oft drüber ausgelassen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein guter
Was denkst du eigentlich über sowas wie stadia nur kurz weil habe ich mich schon oft oft drüber ausgelassen ich glaube dass stadia
in
Zwei Jahren auf dem google friedhof ist
Oder aber wenn google oder aber wenn google es halt einfach als zu wichtig
Ansieht dass es entweder integriert wird in irgendwas anderes
Oder wenn es halt so wichtig ist dass man einfach trotz dass vielen geld ist und man rein was man reingesteckt hat nichts rausbekommt
Trotzdem seinen fuß im gaming segment behalten will dann glaube ich dass es nach wie vor genauso unbedeutend ist wie heute
Von gfors nahe hört man auch wenig gfors nah war eine richtig gute sache
Aber es nehmen jetzt ja immer mehr hersteller ihre spiele raus blizzard ist weg wer ist noch alles weg
Wer ist wer ist alles weg
Blizzard ist weg
Potesta ist weg
2k in rockstar games ist weg
Potesta ist weg 2k in rockstar games ist weg
Square enix ist weg
Kein wunder das ist nicht mehr da ist ja nichts mehr da
Ja, also ich ne coole sache aber ich glaube die haben den wurde das zu gefährlich
Die wollen alle ihren eigenen scheiß machen von der von der von der vom ansatz her fand ich die forst nah am besten
Heiliger bimmer sieben monate
Becken aus den usa huge musstest du ausreisen weil korona oder
Bist du wieder da
Ja ich fand auch gfors nahe ist von den ganzen streaming an diensten vom konzept her auch dass man halt die spiele nicht neu kaufen muss
fand ich das bisher am besten
Aber ja so ist es halt jetzt wo keiner mehr dabei ist was brauchste was was brauchst du es noch
Und wir gucken mal wir gucken mal ein schönes wir gucken mal in den battlefield video
What is it like to play with perfect aim in battlefield?
Oder wo wir mal ein video von dem wir gucken der wurde das letzte mal empfohlen in dem video dass der richtig geile gameplays hat
Oder wollen wir einen battlefield top plays gucken
Das videos zu alt das gucken wir nicht
Ach so urlaub zu ende ok das leucht natürlich auch ein
schau anime compilation
ne
Schau ich keine anime compilation
Kannst du selbst gucken
Achtung tastatur auf englisch ja ich weiß
Tastatur ist aber nicht auf englisch sondern die sprache ist auf englisch
Tastatur ist auf deutsch
Das habe ich alles so eingestellt
Auch eine sache
Ne ne das video über die neue welches meinst du video über ps5 und neue xbox haben wir nicht geguckt wir haben die ankündigung
Geguckt von der ps5 das ist das ein bisschen hardware reveal und da habe ich ein bisschen mein selbst zu abgegeben
So wir gucken jetzt wir gucken jetzt eine runde battlefield in englisch vor jetzt mal eine runde battlefield zu gucken
Wobei ne wir gucken wir gucken erst mal das kommentierte da labert wegen sein ein bisschen
Huge huge konsolen quali
Aber ich glaube das ist gar ich glaube das ist gar keine konsole das ist pc plus ultra schlechte bitrate ab der ich gehört dass
Dass man jetzt irgendwie weniger bandbreite auf youtube und und twitch und gedöns haben soll angeblich
Wegen corona auslastung und sowas
Ist das jetzt so ich habe davor noch nichts gemerkt
Ups
Bild ausgerechnet die bild
Auch
Ausgerechnet die bild
Die bild
Aber die bild man man die bild
ausgerechnet die bild
also
wenn ich mir so was angucke die bitrate sieht absolut in ordnung aus vollkommen ok da ist nichts niedriger
da ist da ist nichts weniger
wir können wir können es mal ausprobieren
wir gucken mal also am besten am besten guckt man sich so was an wenn man das im vlc startet
macht es im vlc auf und dann
solltet es eigentlich anfangen zu planen
oder nicht weil im vlc kann man sich richtig gut auslager bandbreite so was anscheinend
was ist denn da jetzt kaputt
man kann sich man kann sich auch hier angucken aber das ist nicht so nicht so gut
hier kann man sich auch angucken so
was haben wir da bitrate
ich sehe die bitrate nicht leute seht ihr die bitrate wo steht die bitrate
wo ist die bitrate sehe ich sehe ich nicht bin ich blind
ich sehe die bitrate von dem video nicht
keine ahnung
deswegen gucke ich mir das immer ganz gerne in vlc an und ich finde es doof dass das in vlc
gerade nicht läuft warum läuft das in vlc nicht
update von vlc der hype train stufe 1 der scam train war erfolgreich
ich update immer vlc vielleicht spackt das rum
vlc latest version okay ne war schon okay mag nicht hat kein bock
ich muss mal so machen oder so quote quote vielleicht
okay vlc marking bin ich dann
anderes video ja ich wollte es aber gerade auskommen okay dann gucken wir mal ob das
games für ein video in vlc funktioniert nee warum was ist mit vlc los normalerweise geht
das immer guckt wir haben letztens wir haben letztens im stream sogar noch hier das ist
die playstation präsentation gewesen die haben uns angeguckt hat hat funktioniert
und jetzt geht es irgendwie nimmer
cmd habe ich schon nie gehört das ist einfach ein eigenes terminal programm fenster was
angenehmer ist als das normale als dieses hässliche windows komando zeilen fenster
ja warum auch immer das nicht funktioniert ich weiß es nicht
doch man hat das thumbnail für zwei frames gesehen was heißt dass es halt rum leckt wir
können mal wir können mal eine sache ausprobieren
ich habe dieses live streamer zeug nicht drauf aber wir können mal gucken mit youtube dl was
es da für formate gibt oder hier minus minus groß f
was haben wir hier für formate für das video ja das ist das das ist das beste web mit 13
mbit ungefähr so vollkommen in ordnung also da sehe ich keine getrosselte keine getrosselte
geschichte was auch immer wir gucken mal weiter
das habe ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen was er gemacht hat
nur die default die default quali ist auf twitch geändert worden das ist mir auch schon
aufgefallen
der war cool ohne greifflugzeug aber das ist nix gegen den clip den man im letzten video
gesehen haben der drei gegner abgeschossen hat rausgesprungen ist den gegner glaubt gesniped
hat wieder reingehüpft ist das war schon cool
na also die bitrate von dem video drosseln an sich kann ja den internetprovider nicht
es sei denn der proxy hat irgendwie die videos was mit der ttps zu youtube nicht so ohne weiteres
geht du kannst zwar die bandbreite drosseln bei dein internetprovider kann die bandbreite
drosseln das würde dann aber dazu führen dass die videos stottern weil das und buffern
weil es ja nicht die bandbreite an sich von also weil es ja nicht die die bitrate vom
video ändert
das kann der internetanbieter gar nicht machen richtig
also der internetprovider könnte es machen aber das würde nicht zu dem gewünschten
effekt führen
dann müsstest du wenn es dein internetprovider macht dann würde das video hier buffern
dann müsstest du von hand runter stellen bis es halt geht also wie man das öfters bei
wo davon machen muss
ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung twinkler
oder media
das war ein nicer hit
handel
Oder eher Far Cry 3.
Bam!
Moving on, a more conventional top play sent in from Dexter, this one is with the AEK 971 on Zavod TDM.
We've seen a few clips like this in the past on the top plays, but not for a while, and it's refreshing to see some nice infantry action focused on good positioning and accuracy on a map that really excels for infantry gameplay.
It's good on Conquest, fairly decent on Rush, and the TDM I think it's also really nice, especially after they removed the ladders that enable you to get on the roof, although that was quite a few years ago.
Stimmt!
Ja Pollo, du hast recht, das haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Das kommt mir nämlich auch gerade sehr bekannt vor, und das obwohl es von Oktober 2019 ist.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir das hier vielleicht noch nicht kennen.
Auch Oktober 2019.
Wenn wir das jetzt auch schon gesehen haben, dann ist es vorbei.
Battlefield 3 und 4 starten mit einem Clip von Dusty auf Pearl Markets, ein Spiel von Rush, die ACW-R in der Engineer-Klasse, komplett zerstört die Gegner, die versuchten zu pushen und das Ziel zu diffusen.
Ah, wie sie reinrennen!
Du kannst die Videos liken? Nee, ich kann die Videos nicht liken, weil ich hier eingeloggt bin.
Das ist Konsolengameplay. Das muss Konsolengameplay sein, das ist so verschwommen.
Dann hast du hier so einen Fake-Face-Typ im Squad, das ist so typische Konsolenleute, die Face im Kleintag haben, außer man sieht es hier als Playstation.
Sprey, Sprey, Sprey, Sprey.
Bisschen, bisschen dunkel, ne? So, jetzt bitte wieder PC-Auflösung. Ah, yes.
Die hat er aber schon gebashed.
Wahrscheinlich kriegt er, wahrscheinlich kriegt er voll die Flames wieder, so nach dem Motto, fucking Noob-Shotgun!
Zack. Oh. Was ist das für eine Map? Ist das Golf-O-Forman? Was ist das für eine Map? Ja, das ist Golf-O-Forman, ne?
Iiih, iiih.
Battlefield 1, aah. Oh, das ist aber trotzdem nice, aber trotzdem nice.
Was? Wo kehrst du? Er hat einen Hitmarker gekriegt und weiter? Ne, ich glaub, die haben wir noch nicht geguckt.
Zack. Bam. Tja, passiert.
IVT, Stufe 1, dankeschön, huge sub. Ah, so Plays sind immer cool zu gucken.
Das ist, okay, der hofft, dass der reinfliegt. Da ist sehr viel Glück dabei. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie die Map heißt.
Oder ist das Caspian Border in Battlefield 4? Ne, ne, das ist nicht, das ist diese, diese, das ist die andere. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie heißt.
Das ist die andere Battlefield 4 Map. Das ist auch ein Remake, ne?
Ach, keine Ahnung. Ich kann mir die nicht merken. Das ist Battlefield 3? Stimmt, das ist, ein Gott, sieht das ähnlich aus. Meine Güte.
Das, was ist das für ne Map? Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Harvest Day hier, aber es wird kein Harvest Day sein.
Ah, das ist doch, das ist die Armored Kill Map, wo es auch diesen Panzer versus Panzermodus drauf gab, oder? Armored Shield aus Armored Kill, ja.
Der fliegt jetzt voll rein. Bam! Oh, das war halt in Battlefield 3 geil, wenn du einfach mal so predicted hast, irgendwo in den Himmel und zack, fliegt der Jet rein.
Ja, das ist Glück. Das ist Glück pur. Das ist Glück pur.
Doch, doch, die Montage haben wir auch schon gesehen. Die haben wir auch schon gesehen. Die Granate zu dem Heli, da kann ich mich dran erinnern, die haben wir auch schon gesehen. Meine Güte, gibt es irgendwas, was wir noch nicht gesehen haben?
Das, ja, das haben wir auch schon geguckt. Das haben wir auch schon geguckt. Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Mit der Granate an den Heli.
Eigentlich ein richtig cooler Move, ne? Das hatten wir ja, ne? Den Granaten-Kill gegen den Heli merkt man sich. Twitch Prime, 4 Monate, Niels FPS, kap.
Der Klopapier, nee, Klopanisser. Klopapier wäre jetzt ein besserer Name heutzutage gewesen. Das ist Epizentrum.
Reckfriss, 6 Monate. Gleich kommt das Scam Train, Leute, hier. Angeschönt für den Zap.
Oh, da stehen sie rum. Die Gegner wieder so richtig hohl im Kopf.
Nosehair, zack, zack. Oh, das ist, so Sniper-Streaks sind in allen Games immer cool zu sehen.
Weißt du, wenn du so Bäm, gekillt, Bolt-Action-Animation, Bäm, gekillt, Bolt-Action. Das sieht immer cooler aus.
Bäm, entschreckt. Das fand ich, das fand ich eine coole Mechanik in Bad Company 2. In Bad Company 2 muss man sagen, war Sniper sowas von kack OP.
Aber generell in Bad Company 2 war alles in irgendeiner Art und Weise OP. Wenn ich mir überlege, in Bad Company 2 als Medic mit einer M60 und einem Art COG obendrauf quer über die Map schießen mit irgendwie 200 Clip oder sowas.
Aber in Bad Company 2 war die Sniper so krass OP. Vor allem die Wanted Range war halt der Wahnsinn und teilweise auf der Konsole hat es ja auch das übelste Auto-Aim, wenn du ein ordentliches Visier drauf hattest.
Aber eine Mechanik fand ich in Bad Company 2 ganz cool und das war dieses Switchen zwischen Sniper und Pistole.
Immer wenn du gesnippert hast, hast du immer danach noch einmal auf Pistole geswitcht und hinterher geschossen, weil du Body-Shots gemacht hast, die nicht gekillt haben.
Und der Pistolen-Shot hat dann gekillt. Also du hast immer in Bad Company 2 Sniper-Schuss, Pistolen geswitcht und noch einmal hinterher geschossen.
Das fand ich eigentlich eine ganz coole Mechanik. Was ist jetzt hier los? Ich bin jetzt reingesuppt ohne Ende hier.
Ich bin jetzt reingesuppt ohne Ende hier. Da war er am Start. Akenas 99 und Sergeant Ormel. Und Phoenix. Einmal sieben Monate, dann ein neuer Sub und dann drei Monate. Huge Subs. Wahnsinn.
Die nächste Clip ist eine 10-Mann, diese wieder an Noshau Canals.
Fährst du dieses Jahr in den Urlaub?
Nö.
Hab gestern in Overwatch gegen Klopapier und Klondeckel 23 gespielt.
Endlich mal jemand, der sich ordentlich benennt.
Was, mach mal den Subscriber, nice. Du meinst den hier.
Bei Bad Company konnte man sich hier hinlegen. Ja, das stimmt.
Das hat aber irgendwie dazugehört.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, gerade für Rush,
wir sehen ein sehr schönes Zwischenbildberechnung von seinem Capture-Programm.
Das fand ich schlecht. Gerade in Rush hat es dazu geführt,
auch in Bad Company 2 saßen die Leute am Arsch der Welt und haben rumgesniped.
Ja, haben sie halt in irgendeinem Busch gehockt,
weil Bad Company 2 hatte halt sehr viel so Environment-Maps.
Aber wenn ich mir vorstelle, die hätten sich in Bad Company 2 noch hinlegen können,
das hätte das ganze Game viel langsamer gemacht und Rush viel weniger spaßig.
Und Bad Company 2 hatte ja auch nahezu perfekte M-Com-Platzierungen,
also sprich, du musstest genau gucken, weil du dich nicht hinlegen konntest,
wie stellst du dich ans M-Com, wie rennst du da rum.
Manchmal war es besser, du hast das M-Com quasi von außen, du hast quasi die Mauer kaputt gemacht
und hast das M-Com von außen geaimt, weil du halt von außen ein bisschen tiefer gestanden hast.
Das war richtig cool.
Also ich fand das einen Design-Ansatz, den fand ich in Bad Company 2 sinnvoll.
Oh, jetzt kriegen sie aufs Maul.
So geil.
Ist der blind?
Das haben wir schon mal gesehen und ich weiß auch, dass ich mich damals genau an der gleichen Stelle
das Gleiche gefragt habe, ob der blind ist.
Hast du noch mal in Battlefield 5 gespielt? Nee.
Ich will mal wieder ein modernes Battlefield.
Von Leuten, wohlgemerkt von Leuten, die wissen, wie man ein Battlefield macht.
Bad Company 2 hat ja auch noch ein bisschen mehr,
aber es gibt auch noch ein bisschen mehr.
Bad Company 3 gab es ja Gerüchte, dass Bad Company 3 kommt
und dann gab es Gerüchte, dass Bad Company 3 eingestellt wurde.
Also Gerüchte, offiziell hat man nichts gehört.
Jetzt kommt erst mal Modern Warfare 2.
Was kommt denn dieses Jahr?
Ist es nicht schon raus, dass es Black Ops 5 ist oder so?
Black Ops 6, Black Ops 4, Black Ops 5.
Ist es noch weniger klar, dass Black Ops 5 kommen soll?
Remastered?
Black Ops 5 Cold War, ok.
Mit Skill-Based Matchmaking, hör mal auf.
Ach, die können machen, was sie wollen. Ich warte es ab.
Der Hype ist vorbei.
Ich glaube, jeder Franzose stirbt immer so leicht,
dass jeder sagt seine Crossing oder seine Crossing.
Da denken die sich wahrscheinlich, es ist mit den Leuten los.
Das ist so richtig cringe für Franzosen wahrscheinlich,
wenn man seine Crossing hört.
Geht schreckt, die haben voll auf die Fresse.
Haha, die Gegner.
Oh, Tony Stark.
Na dann.
Da sieht man schon, dass es ein halbwegs aktuelles Gameplay sein muss,
weil als das Game rausgekommen ist,
hat sich noch kein Mensch für das ganze Marvel-Zeug interessiert.
Ah, CoComrad hier am Start.
Ich hab mir noch nie die Leute im Chopper angeguckt.
Die sehen eher aus wie Bankräume aus Hardline da oben.
CoComrad ist nicht aktiv, doch. Nee, nicht, nicht.
Hab ich das nicht aktiv? Oh.
Hab ich das nicht aktiv? Das muss ich gleich ändern.
Moment, Emotes.
Das muss ich gleich aktivieren.
CoComrad. So, Aktivierung ist...
Add to my channel. So, Aktivierung ist raus.
Ist aktiviert, Leute.
Ja, das kann ein bisschen sein, bis FFZ sich sünkt.
Weiß nicht, ob es bei euch geht schon,
aber FFZ müsste sich sünkt und dann geht's.
Vielleicht müsst ihr auch refreshen oder so.
Warte mal, ich refresh mal meinen Chat und guck, ob es dann funktioniert.
Ja, geht, geht.
Funktioniert.
Ich muss aber meinen Chat neu verbinden, dass ich es auch sehe.
Ja, das Time outet er. Er soll sich mal disconnecten.
Er disconnectet sich nicht.
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt ohne CoComrad im Chat leben für diesen Stream.
Aber im Chat selbst geht's.
Ich glaube, es kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ja, das haben wir alle schon gesehen.
Aber trotzdem, ich gucke mir echt gerne Battlefield.
Gibt es... Weißt du, was ich mal gucken muss?
Bad Company 2 Top Plays.
Warte mal, da müssen wir jetzt mal schauen.
Zwei Jahre.
Back to Bad Company. Das gucken wir jetzt.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Bad Company 2 Top Plays. Huge.
Kann er noch leiser reden?
Das ist aber nicht Bad Company 2. Nur mal so.
Ich will es ja nur mal sagen, dass es kein Bad Company 2 ist.
PKP.
Jawoll.
Wie hieß das Ding so?
Ah, PKM, nicht PKP, PKM.
Richtig schnell.
Bad Company 2 hatte auch schon seine Schwächen.
Also das Spotting-System in Kombination mit, dass man durch fast alles durchschießen kann,
war wirklich nicht sonderlich fair.
Also sprich, wenn du gespottet wurdest und warst hinter einem Haus, du hast im Prinzip hier einfach nur auf rote Punkte geschossen.
Es hat jemand gespottet, du hast hinter einer Wand gestanden, hast durch die Wand den Gegner gekillt.
Hast du dein Docker-Compose-Yaml für Nextcloud irgendwo dokumentiert?
Nö, nicht.
Doch, das ist einfach das. Das einzige, was ich angepasst habe, glaube ich, bei Nextcloud im Vergleich zu dem offiziellen ist,
dass ich die Version fest reingeschrieben habe, weil ich nicht will, dass er automatisch einen Upgrade direkt macht, wenn es neu herauskommt.
Hast du mit dem Doom Eternal DRM mitbekommen?
Was ist mit dem Doom Eternal DRM?
Das war richtig cool.
Also ich würde mir gerne mal eine komplette Bad Company 2 Montage angucken, aber es gibt halt keine Gameplays mehr.
Woher auch? Es gibt noch zwei Server, wo was los ist.
Wie war das, der Spotting pliegt relativ lang, ja?
Das Spotting war ziemlich unfair, gerade auf Maps, wo man durch die Sachen durchschießen kann.
Ich meine, der Typ ist gespottet, der würde jetzt hinter das Haus rennen, du schießt einfach komplett durch das Haus durch und er ist down.
Moment, das ist kein, ah, übrigens eine, wo ich hier gerade sitze, eine meiner, Terran Highway, eine meiner absolut Lieblings-Battlefield-Maps.
Das ist total underrated, das Ding.
Das ist total underrated, eine richtig geile Rush-Map, übelst nice, ja?
Eine wirkliche, eines meiner absolut Lieblings-Maps, Terran Highway.
Gerade die Kombination aus Panzer-Action am Anfang, dann Infanterie-Action in den Häusern, richtig nice Map.
Ähm, ich dachte, das ist alles Bad Company 2.
Eine Version ohne DRM geleakt, ja, da bin ich nicht böse drum.
Best Moments, okay, gucken wir das mal, ich will einfach noch ein bisschen Bad Company, ein bisschen Bad Company 2 gucken.
Äh.
What?
YouTube bugged.
Ja, Beste, wir sind hier rumgeschneibert.
Guck mal, das Video hat auch gute Bewertung, ja, scheint ganz gut zu sein.
Ich mein, eins muss man sagen, das Treffer-Feedback in Bad Company 2 war ein bisschen schwammig, ne?
Du hast nicht so genau gecheckt, wann wie wo was gehitted hat.
Was ist jetzt los?
What the fuck?
Vor allem haben wir ja noch Murra.
Hier konnte man von unten die Bombe legen.
Naja, das ist ja Standard, das ist ja Standard, das ist ja Standard.
Der repariert jetzt nicht, oder?
Ja, das kann passieren.
Jetzt so super funny und best Moments ist es jetzt, ist es jetzt.
Ich brauche richtig geile Bad Company Plays Leute, wo sind sie?
9 years ago, nein.
Und dann haben wir hier was auch immer.
Coronavirus Alert, Bad Company 2 Top Plays, ah yes, excellent.
Den gibt's noch?
Alter, es gibt Sergeant Enigma noch, kennt ihr den noch?
Der hat damals die geilsten Schneiber Clips gemacht in Bad Company 2.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es den noch gibt.
Der hat die geilsten Schneiber Clips gemacht.
Nice, den müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Oh Monka Toss Musik, bam.
Ist das so Oasis?
Ist das Oasis Remake?
Also die Map?
Schon.
Das hat so richtig so ein 2012er Vibe, irgendwie so diese Videos.
Auch mit dem Intro und der Musik und so und dem riesen Foff.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Arnele, Arnele Squad, äh Quad.
Bam.
Das war cool.
Das war nice.
Ich hab gar nicht genau erkannt, wo er dagegen gefahren ist.
Wo ist er denn dagegen gefahren?
Ah in den Panzer, in den Panzer rein, ah yes.
Silence.
Oh cool, dass er den noch erwischt hat.
Nee, der hat er gar nicht erwischt.
Das war noch von, Killcounter hat geleckt.
Beste, das ist so geil gewesen, die Motion Sensors und die One Hit Kills von der Schneiber.
Bam.
Guckt euch mal die One Hit Range an, habt ihr das gesehen?
Bam, next.
Das war mal wahnsinnig OP.
SV98, ja SV98 oder M50.
M50 hab ich auch gerne gespielt.
Die hatte glaube nur 5 Schuss oder so, aber die hatte eine etwas höhere One Hit Range noch.
Was geht da eigentlich gerade ab?
Korn, Klassiker Nigma.
Ich seh nix.
Bam.
Müsste eigentlich mal gereppt werden.
Nee, gibt's nicht.
Repariert wird nicht.
Gut Sniper musstest du Magnum Ammo spielen.
Magnum Ammo hat ja die One Shot Range erhöht.
Sniper ohne Magnum Ammo war für'n Arsch.
Bam.
Und was ich halt auch geil fand, dass man das C4 50 km weit werfen konnte.
Da kommt er wieder.
Sehr nett von ihm, dass er wieder kommt.
Bam, bam, bam und Panzer von der Seite in your face.
Habt ihr den Kitswitch gesehen?
Huge Kitswitch.
Womit kann man Gui in Java machen?
Die nicht Java FX ist keine Ahnung von Java.
Das war ein cooler Play, das war ein richtig nicer Play.
Da fand man sich auch so geil in Bad Company, zweimal man solche Plays gemacht hat.
Ich hab auch relativ viel Kitswitch dann später, als man erst mal gecheckt hat, wie geil das ist.
Genau mein Gedanke, warum war der nicht tot.
Zack.
Next.
Pock.
Man sieht gar nichts wegen der Lampe.
Oh, das wär cool gewesen.
Wo sind Gegner?
Ich glaub da nicht wirklich, dass es jemand Ammo gibt.
Das haben die Leute ungern gemacht in Bad Company 2.
Zumal in Bad Company 2 auch nicht so viele Sturmsoldaten am Start waren für Ammo.
Jetzt muss man wieder was killen.
Die Sniper Kills haben sich schon gut angefühlt in dem Game.
Der war nice.
Jetzt erst mal anstälzen mit C4.
Und jetzt BAM in your face.
Ja, du konntest das C4 über die halbe Map schmeißen.
Da wird nicht entschärft.
Oh, das war knapp.
Das fand ich cool, dieses Umswitchen zwischen Sniper und Pistole.
Oh, Drohne.
Da gab es in Bad Company 2 auch immer die Spezialisten, die als erstes an diesen Drohnenmonitor gerannt sind und dann die ganze Runde an der Drohne rumgeflogen sind.
Oder Roadkills mit der Drohne.
Okay, da war er nicht gut getroffen.
Das waren die größten Ottos.
Die standen wirklich die ganze Map-Runde an der Drohne.
Der hätte aber ein bisschen schneller gehen müssen.
Ach, ist das schön mal wieder ein bisschen Bad Company 2 zu sehen.
Okay, das war Pech.
Der ist einfach stehen geblieben anstatt weiter zu laufen, wie er das ursprünglich gemacht hat.
Zack.
Okay, das ist halt auch komplette Honk der Gegner.
Da hat er nichts gecheckt.
Der Panzer, wie er in das einschützende Haus einfach reinfährt.
Ja, das wird nahm älter und spielt aber keiner mehr, oder?
Keine Maps mehr.
Oh, G36.
Das war eine Sache, die war in Bad Company 2 wirklich gut. Jede Waffe war einzigartig.
Da war keine Waffe drinne, einfach um sie drinne zu haben.
Quatsch mit Sauce, das ist auch Neuauflage von Bad Company 2, weil die sollen einfach ein ordentliches Bad Company 3 machen.
Und jetzt Reload Cancel.
BF 1943, ja ein bisschen auf der Xbox damals.
Also das war ja diese Arcade-Variante.
Oder? Bring ich das durch? Nee, warte mal, 1943 war das Original, oder? Oder war 1943 das Arcade-Ding auf der Xbox?
In 1942 war das Original, 1943 war das Arcade-Ding.
Oder? Wir hatten da vorbeigeschossen.
Eine Sache, die ich auch blöd fand, dass es keine Helz-Anzeige gab.
Man musste sich immer auf gut Glück in Midi-Pack stellen und hoffen, dass der Typ irgendwann macht...
oder so. Das war so ein komisches Geräusch, was das Midi-Pack gemacht hat.
Und BAM! So muss das sein.
Sniper war die OP-Klasse in dem ganzen Game.
Konntest alles zerstören mit C4 über wahnsinnige Range.
One-Hit-Waffen, also eigentlich die besten Waffen mit übelster One-Hit-Range.
Mit die besten Gadgets, also für Solo-Owner war das die beste Klasse.
Nice, aber schön, wie der Bad Company 2 hingeguckt. Das muss jetzt mal sein.
So, was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl? Battle Finale haben wir jetzt erst mal genug geschaut.
Was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl? Die besten Spiele, die es gerade kostenlos gibt.
Dann hätten wir noch zu bieten ein neues PC-Bild, Windows 98.
Der meint mit neuem PC-Bild wirklich einen neuen PC-Zusammenbau aus 2000 oder so.
So altes Zeug gucke ich ja gern. Und wisst ihr, warum ich so altes Zeug gerne gucke?
Weil ich kann das schlecht beschreiben.
Irgendwie, wenn ich alte Hardware sehe, sei es CD-Laufwerke, Festplatten mit IDE-Kabel und sowas,
irgendwie komme ich mir da übelst Jung bei vor.
Das klingt jetzt blöd. Ich bin erst 35, ich bin keine 70.
Aber ich komme mir dann übelst Jung bei vor, weil ich mir so...
Ah ja, IDE-Kabel.
Nee, nix, RIP. Stream geht immer noch.
35 schon eine andere Risikogruppe.
Feels Corona, man.
Hast schon Warzone gespielt? Nee, habe ich auch überhaupt keinen Hang dazu.
Wir gucken das jetzt.
On June 25th, 1998, Microsoft released Windows 98 to the world.
June 25th, 2018 marks the 20-year anniversary of its release.
As a way of celebrating this, I thought it would be fun to build an all-new Windows 98 gaming computer.
Was hat er denn? Ich muss mal kurz Lautstärke gucken, ob die jetzt okay ist. Ja, Lautstärke geht, ne. Was hat er denn, was hat er? Ich muss mal gucken, was er am Start hat. Was hat er denn? Eine Pentium 3 oder Zeleron-Board, okay. Pentium 3 CPU, eine 100!
Oh, aber ne gute, ne gute Intel, ne gute Intel 100-Ambit-Netzwerk-Karte. Microsoft Natural Keyboard, das war damals voll angesagt, diese ergonomischen Keyboards.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt, bis heute, keine Ahnung warum. Ich hab keine Ahnung warum, ich fand die ergonomischen Keyboards damals schon wahnsinnig unergonomisch.
Aber irgendwie waren, ich kann's mir nicht erklären, aber die waren damals total angesagt und es hatte auch jeder so eine ergonomische Microsoft-Maus, so eine Intelli-Maus.
Und ich war damals so blöd und hab mir ne Intelli-Maus-Explorer gekauft, äh, aber die erste, die erste Wireless, dieses Ding hier, dieses Teil.
Da war ich so blöd und hab mir damals ne Wireless-Maus gekauft, zu der Zeit, wo Wireless-Mäus noch richtig scheiße waren. Das müsste auch so 98 oder 99, 2000 im Dreh gewesen sein.
Und damals waren Wireless-Mäuse wirklich kacke. Ähm, da mussten fette AAA-Batterien rein.
Oder AAA? Nee, was sind die normalen? Da mussten fette Batterien rein auf jeden Fall. Das sieht man hier unten. Fette Batterien mussten da rein.
Das Ding war schwer, das Ding war unhandlich, das Ding hatte Übertragungsstörungen und die Abtastrate war scheiße.
Ja, mittlerweile ist Wireless viel besser. Guckt euch mal an die ganzen Konsolen-Controller gehen da mittlerweile auch wunderbar über Wireless.
Und damals hab ich, was hab ich damit gespielt? CS 05 oder so. Und ich hab mich gewundert, warum ich gesagt habe.
Und kaum hab ich ne richtige Maus angeschlossen. Damals noch hier ne, ne, ne, die erste Razer-Maus mit, mit Ball.
Ja, genau, die erste Razer-Maus mit Ball. Boomslang 2000, genau. Auf einmal war ich richtig gut.
E-Spawns-Rally, ja. Das war ein riesen fettes Ding damals. Das war die erste Razer-Maus, da, als Razer noch richtig, äh, äh, richtig cool war, ja.
Ähm. Nee, die erste hatte ne, die erste hatten nen Ball, die erste hatten nen Ball.
Die erste hatten nen Ball. Die Razer hatte eine Maus mit nem Ball. Danach hatten die glaub ich nur noch optische.
Man siehts leider die Maus nicht von unten, aber die alle ersten hatten nen Ball. Und die waren auch nicht Wireless. Und ab da gings dann richtig ab.
Ach, wie schön, ja. Äh, so. Und für die, die sagt, warum ist dieses Natural-Keyboard-Chain, das hat ne Voodoo 5. Oh, huge Voodoo 5. Äh, Soundplaster.
Und erkennt man nicht, erkennt man nicht, äh, ähm, Sidewinder. Das ist ein Sidewinder-Headset oder so, wahrscheinlich.
Oder Controller oder, oder, oder, oder Flugstick oder so. Und hier oben nen DVD-Brenner. Hohoho.
Und, was war denn damals angesagt? SD-RAM? Müsste SD-RAM gewesen sein, ne? Normaler SD-RAM.
Edoram war es nicht mehr, es war wahrscheinlich normaler SD-RAM.
Ok, guck mal, guck mal mal weiter.
Ah, hier hat er es, hier hat er es. Ok. Äh, 1000, oder 120G Festplatte. Keine Ahnung, was das ist. So ne komische Maus. Ähm, ne extra USB-Add-on-Karte.
Deswegen hatte man damals auch so riesen, so riesen Gehäuse, weil da zig Add-on-Karten rein mussten.
Dazu teilweise Rechner mit 5, 6 Add-on-Karten. Äh, ja, diese kleinen Foot-Speaker, diese kleinen Foot-Speaker, die hatte man damals auch.
Das waren diese Speaker, wo, ähm, die haben dann irgendwie 35, 35 Euro gekostet. Und da stand dann drauf, 5000 Watt Aktiv-Speaker.
Da haben die sich, haben die sich komplett übertroffen, ne? Wo auch immer diese oder, oder 2000, oder 2000 Watt, wo auch immer das herkommen soll.
Aus dem Klinke-Stecker, oder was? Oh, fuck.
Oje. Leute. Monkeys. Äh, gehts wieder? Ah, anscheinend gehts wieder. Ok. Nice. Ah, yes, excellent.
Äh, wo bin ich gerade stehen geblieben? Genau, bei diesen komischen Lautsprechern. Und, ähm, wo auch immer die 2000, sonst was, Watt, was die da draufschrieben, wo auch immer die herkommen sollen, über das Klinke-Kabel, oder was?
Das war so die typische, und man hat sich damals eingeredet, man hat die übelst geile, Hi-Fi, High-Quality, ähm, krassen Audio-Equipment am Start, wenn man so ein Crap bei sich stehen hatte.
Äh, Sidewinder-Joystick, ja, nice, hatte ich damals auch einen. Äh, Sidewinder-Gamepad hatte ich nicht, das war zu Xbox-Zeiten noch. DVD-Laufwerk.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice. Und das, also, ich bin echt mal gespannt. Und dann noch ein Internetradio, ja. Damals kam es sich ja geil vor, dass man Radio quasi ohne Radio übers Internet hören konnte.
Oh, ein fünfeinhalb, äh, Floppy. Muss ich ehrlich sagen, war ein bisschen vor meiner Zeit mit fünfeinhalb Floppy. Ich hatte nur dreieinhalb, dreieinhalb, ähm, und, ähm, CD, später.
Was ist das da unten? Das ist eine Diskettenaufbewahrungsbox. Und ein 17 Zoll, ein 17 Zoll Bildschirm war aber schon, schon Mittelklasse gehoben, äh. Und ein neues Netzteil, ja.
Nice. Schauen wir mal, da bin ich mal gespannt. Guck mal, auch Absolut-Lied-Lied-Video-Laufzeit. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Also ohne Scheiß den Kram heute original verpackt oder, oder zu, nicht, nicht original verpackt, aber mit original Verpackung noch zu finden ist bestimmt saumäßig schwer.
Ich hatte damals, wo ich gerade gesagt habe, 17 Zoll, ich hatte dann, ich hatte damals einen, ich glaube 21 Zoll, äh, Samsung-Monitor war das. Das Ding war ultraschwer, das hat keine Ahnung, 40 Kilo oder so gewogen. Und mit dem Ding ist man natürlich dann auch irgendwo hingefahren. Ich hab mich totgeschleppt.
Oh. Big Tower. Jawoll. Das war der Schwanzvergleich der, der, der 1998 bis 2000 Jahre. Äh, wer hat den größten Big Tower? Minitower, Dings, Minitower, Big Tower muss das damals sein.
Das war der, das war der richtige Schwanzvergleich damals, aber man darf auch nicht vergessen, man hat es teilweise schon gebraucht. Wenn du überlegst CD-Laufwerk, DVD-Laufwerk, ein Brenner vielleicht, äh, auf jeden Fall nennt es Kettenlaufwerk.
Innen drinnen zwei, drei Festplatten, je nachdem was man hatte. Äh, Endonkarten, Soundkarten, Netzwerkkarten, vielleicht USB oder sonst was. Also man hat es, man hat es teilweise schon gebraucht. Bei den aller, aller meisten Leuten hätte es auch ein stinknormaler mittlerer Minitower getan. Aber Big Tower war halt einfach nice. Und man fand sich geil, wenn man den Big Tower hatte.
Also ich muss sagen, mein Alltime Favorite Computer Case ist, äh, immer noch die, die Fractal Design Air, was auch immer Serie, F4, F5, F6 was gibt. Das ist wirklich die besten Gehäuse, die ich je hatte. Die sind einfach top. Die alten sind retro cool, aber besser gefallen mir die neuen.
Hast du den Rant über Bluetooth von Techquickie gesehen? Nee, schick mal. Können wir gucken. Oh, Monster8570. Habt ihr da vielleicht noch was übrig für mich? Alles Zeug. Hast du den Rant über Bluetoothquickie gesehen? Nee, schick mal. Also wie gesagt, können wir gleich noch mal gucken. Aber erstmal muss ich ihm zugucken, wie er das echt anbaut.
Das haben wir uns gerade alles angeguckt. Und es war schon richtig viel. 120G Festplatte. 120G Festplatte ist ordentlich.
Webcam. Ja, diese, diese Drecks, diese Kack-Mikros hatte man damals auch. Da hatte man vor sich so ein Standmikrofon stehen mit der miesesten Kack-Quali aller Zeiten. Und hat sich eingebildet, man hat was richtig Gutes.
Und diese Happy-Familien-Bilder auf der Hardware damals immer. So nach dem Motto, oh ja Papa, guck mal, eine Webcam.
Wisst ihr noch, als Microsoft die Kinect-Cam auf Xbox Live ausgeschaltet hat nach diesem Skandal, weil Leute bei irgendeinem Family-Kartenspiel ihren Schwanz für die Kinect-Cam gehalten haben.
Da hat Microsoft damals die Kinect-Cam ausgeschaltet. Das war doch ein Riesenskandal. Das gab irgendwelche casual Xbox Live Spiele mit Kamera.
Und da haben die Leute halt das gemacht, was die Leute halt im Internet nun mal machen. Hat sich die Hose runtergezogen. Und das war halt ein casual Spiel, wo halt auch Kinder drin waren.
Und da war Microsoft überhaupt nicht erfreut drüber. Doch, müsst ihr mal nachgucken. Da haben wir die Kinect-Cam damals ausgeschaltet. Weil die Leute sich die Hose runtergezogen haben.
Die Leute sind halt ein bisschen gestört, ja. Was geht mit dem? Der hat ja hier echt ein halbes Lagerhaus voll. Weil das da hinten, der Monitor ist aber zu neu.
Windows 98. Ja, da hat er recht. Da hat er recht, ganz ehrlich. Alte Netzteile waren scheiße. Also oftmals scheiße. Das waren wirklich billigste China-Crap.
Das war die Zeit, wo noch niemand das zu wertschätzen wusste, ein gutes Netzteil. Man hatte so LC-Power und sowas. Man hatte die billigste Netzteile.
Und eine Sache, was neben Big Tower damals auch Schwanzvergleich war. Wie viel Watt hat dein Netzteil? Ich hab ein 750 Watt Netzteil. Huge Poggers. Wahnsinn. Gebraucht hat man das auch selten.
Wobei viele Hardware damals auch ordentlich Strom gezogen hat. Gerade zu Pentium 4 Zeiten war das wahnsinnig, was die an Strom gezogen haben.
Zu Pentium 4 Zeiten, weil ja, Microsoft ist ja auf die großartige Idee gekommen, nicht etwa, dass ihre CPUs zu viel Strom verbrauchen, beziehungsweise zu heiß werden, zu viel Abwärmer produzieren, sondern Intel wollte ja damals mit BTX ein neues Netzwerkstandard durchsetzen. Was erzähl ich für ein scheiß Netzwerk? Gehäuse! Meine Güte, ein bisschen Kopf zusammenhalten.
Neue Gehäuse standard durchsetzen, die ihre CPUs besser kühlt, weil ATX zu Noob war. So, egal, weiter.
Das älteste, das wahrscheinlich schlecht ist in seiner Box. Aber nun ist der Geburtstag hier und es ist Zeit, den Computer zusammenzulegen. Also schauen wir uns mal an ein paar der wichtigsten Sachen an. Starten wir mit der CPU.
Seht ihr noch von dem Pentium 2, wie die ausgesehen haben? Das ist für Leute, die damals nicht dabei waren. Pentium 2 sahen komplett ungewöhnlich aus. Hier, guckt mal. Das war die einzige Intel CPU, die jemals in so einem komischen Stackkarte gekommen ist.
Danach und davor sahen CPUs aus wie CPUs, nämlich so. Also das ist jetzt Pentium 2 auf so einem Board. Und das war halt im Konsumerbereich komplett neu. Und ich fand's cool irgendwo, ja? Und ich dachte damals, das Ding ist die CPU. Das stimmt ja gar nicht. Die CPU ist das Ding da drinnen.
Und das war die einzige so Konsumer-CPU, die so eine Slot-Stack-Technik hatte. Danach sahen die Dinger ja immer wieder so aus. Bei der letzten ICR, weiß ich nicht, kann sein. Aber mir ist bis jetzt noch nichts untergekommen.
Gab's das nicht bis Pentium 4? Nee. Pentium 3 sahen wieder ganz normal aus. Pentium 3 sahen wieder so... Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt. Anscheinend gab's das später auch noch. Aber es hat so gut wie keiner verbaut.
Also Pentium 3 hat man eigentlich wieder ganz normal auf das Board gelegt. Und Pentium 4 ist auch. Vielleicht war das so eine Übergangsgeschichte. Aber so wirklich präsent war bei mir im Kopf nur Pentium 2 in diesem Design.
Guck, sein Pentium 3 ist ja auch ganz normaler. Intel CPU. Zum Glück betreibt er keine AMD-CPU auf einem Intel Board. Das funktioniert ja gar nicht zusammen.
Es war jeder mal in der Lage, dass er an sowas geglaubt hat. Es war jeder mal so noob und hat gesagt, Nvidia-Grafikkarten nur auf Intel-Mainboards und Intel-CPUs nur in Intel.
Oder ich kaufe alles von Intel, weil das besser ist. Ich kaufe alles von AMD, weil das besser funktioniert. Was ein Schwachsinn.
Eine der Sachen, die tatsächlich mal herstellerübergreifend funktioniert haben, ist die Schnittstellen im PC.
Was haben wir denn? AGP? Erstmal ein AGP-Steckplatz. PCI, PCI, PCI, PCI, OK. Fünfmal PCI und einmal AGP. Was ist das? Was ist das da in der Mitte?
Kein ISA mehr, nee. Was ist denn das da? Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, es ist ein übergroßer SATA, aber ist es nicht.
M2-Slot. Ich habe legit keine Ahnung, was das hier ist. Rest erkennen wir ja hier. Mikrofon, Audio, Line, Netzwerk, USB, wahrscheinlich USB 1, 1 oder so. VGA, seriell, parallel.
Das hier, Maus und Tastatur, PS2, nochmal USB. Ich kann sagen, das ist HDMI, aber in der Zeit garantiert noch keine HDMI.
Und natürlich gute alte BIOS-Batterie. Die darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen. IDE, IDE, floppy, ATX-Connector, wahrscheinlich nochmal USB. Connector für Front-Panel vom Gehäuse.
Chipsatz, dachte ich damals auch noch sehr präsent. Schön irgendwelche Spulen, die fiepen können.
Nice. Ein nice Sport. Hier oben ist noch Stromstecker. Das da ist ein CPU-Stromstecker, nee. Oder? So einen habe ich noch nie gesehen. Wir werden es ja gleich sehen, wenn das anschließt.
Damals haben die CPUs noch keinen extra Strom gebraucht, meines Wissens nach.
Stimmt. Warum hat er drei RAM-Slots? Das ist auch heute sehr untypisch.
Oh. Danach war es vorbei. Danach war es vorbei mit Voodoo. Also die ganzen Voodoo-Geschichten waren ja eh nur zu Voodoo 1 und Voodoo 2-Zeiten richtig must-have, beziehungsweise überlegen geil im Vergleich zu allem anderen.
Mit Voodoo 3 hat es schon nachgelassen und spätestens seit Nvidia mit dem ersten TNT und vor allem der TNT 2-Geschichte rausgekommen ist, wie gut ich mich mit alter Hardware auskenne.
Das war noch die Zeit, wo ich mich für den Kram interessiert habe. Mittlerweile ist Hardware für mich Hardware. Als die mit der TNT 2 damals rausgekommen sind, wurde es ja eng.
Weil dann hat es so eine Karte, die konnte ordentlich 2D und die konnte 3D besser als die Voodoo-Karten sogar. Halt richtig Boomer, klar. Und da wurde es eng.
Weil man darf nicht vergessen, die ersten zwei Voodoo-Karten, die musstest du durchschleifen, damit du überhaupt 2D anzeigen konntest.
Also sprich, du konntest nicht einfach eine Voodoo-Karte einbauen und deinen Desktop darstellen. Das ging nicht. Die konnten kein 2D. Du musstest dein 2D durchschleifen von einer normalen Grafikkarte durch deine Voodoo-Grafikkarte.
Da hat auch ein bisschen die Bildqualität drunter gelitten. Also der Desktop sah durchgeschleift durch eine Voodoo-Karte nicht mehr ganz so scharf aus. Man darf nicht vergessen, das war damals alles analog VGA.
Da gab es dann so richtige Voodoo-Path-Through-Cable. So richtig fette, genau hier.
Da gab es so richtig fette, isolierte VGA-Kabel, wo man dann von der 2D-Grafikkarte in die Voodoo-Grafikkarte rein ist. Und hier kam dann entweder das durchgeschleift 2D-Bild raus oder direkt 3D, wenn es von der Voodoo berechnet wurde.
Da hat man mal zwangsläufig zwei gebraucht.
Doppelder Lüfter. Überlegt euch mal, wie popelig damals Grafikkarten ausgesehen haben. Max, warum machst du keine Videos? Ich nehme heute was auf. Wie popelig damals Grafikkarten ausgesehen haben. Und stellt euch mal vor, es gab eine Zeit, in der Grafikkarten tatsächlich in einen Slot gepasst haben.
Kann man sich das heute noch vorstellen? Heute brauchen Grafikkarten zwei, drei Slots, zweieinhalb, drei Slots. Die Grafikkarte damals hat in einen Slot gepasst und die hat damals auch garantiert keine 1200 Euro gekostet.
Die hat wahrscheinlich was um, keine Ahnung, 300, 400 Euro, wenn es hoch kommt, gekostet und war high-end.
Ach, das war die Geschichte. Das war die Geschichte mit genau, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, mit zwei Grafikkarten auf einer Grafikkarte. SLI gab es ja schon lange vor Nvidia.
Und man muss sagen, zu der damaligen Zeit, als Voodoo 2 SLI angesagt hat, hat das für meinen Geschmack auch relativ gut funktioniert, weil alle diesen proprietären Voodoo-Kram verwendet haben.
But before we try and put these parts together and make it post, we need two more things. First, the new monitors. A typical VGA CRT...
Was, das Stromkabel lebt gefährlich, warum?
First, the company that...
Das hier, ach was.
The new monitors.
A typical VGA CRT... Was meinst du mit proprietären Voodoo-Kram? Wie hieß denn das? Glide? Glide 3DFX oder so?
Das Ding, was beliebt war vor OpenGL und Direct3D. Glide hieß das, glaube ich.
Oder irgendwie so ähnlich. Glide. 3DFX Glide gilt. 3DFX gilt. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es genau heißt. Das war die 3D-Schnittstelle, bevor es DirectX und OpenGL so richtig mainstream gab.
Ich mein, das hier.
Hier.
Das.
Diablo 2 hatte... Man kann heute Diablo 2 mit so einem Rapper laufen lassen. Was das nach, was das emuliert, weil es dann besser läuft.
17 Zoll CRT. Das ist schonmal ordentlich. Hatten nicht viele.
Wobei, wenn man zu Pentium... Doch, hatten viele. Wenn man zu Pentium 3-Zeiten schaut...
In Pentium 3-Zeiten haben ja langsam, aber sicher hat es auch angefangen, dass die Leute LCDs verwendet haben. Langsam, aber sicher.
Das war die Zeit, wo ich mein 21 Zoll, 40 Kilo Samsung-Monitor hatte.
Davor, da hatte ich auch ein bisschen kleineren.
Ich hatte ein Monitor von... Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die hießen. So ganz komisch. Irgendwas mit Y.
Monitor Y. Yakumo oder sowas? Genau. Yakumo. Hab ich nie wieder gehört.
Yakumo-Monitor.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es die gar nicht mehr. Und von denen hatte ich ein 17 Zoll Monitor.
Und der war richtig kacke. Der hatte kaum Helligkeit und hat geflimmert ohne Ende.
Was ist das?
Das ist ja cool!
Guck mal, man kann quasi das zum Mainboard installieren.
Rausnehmen. Das heißt, man kann das Zeug draufbauen und danach reinschieben. Das ist doch richtig nice.
Als CPUs noch Pins hatten.
Heute gibt es ja keine Pins mehr.
Spritz mal richtige Wärmeleitpaste drauf.
Ich bin ja immer begeistert, wie wenig advanced und wie wenig sophisticated der Kram war.
Einfach zack drauf, zack drauf, zack drauf, klips, klips, klips. Gut ist.
Kein 50 Meter Tower-Kühler, 30 Stromkabel an Grafikkarte, Mainboard, CPU und sonst was.
Einfach rein, klips, gut ist.
Was? Ryzen hat Pins? Wirklich?
Ich dachte, Pins sind komplett out. CPUs haben doch schon in den letzten 10 Jahren keine Pins mehr.
Oh, oh.
Ich hab kein Ryzen mehr.
Oh, oh, das sieht nicht gut aus, Leute. Das sieht nicht gut aus hier.
RIP.
Und lass mich raten, jetzt geht's, weil sonst hättet ihr das Video nicht aufgenommen.
Post-Beep. Habt ihr gehört?
Ah, yes. Post-Beep.
Hat ja gar nicht mehr auf, ey.
Damals war PC-Bauen noch ne Aufgabe, ne Tagesaufgabe.
Oh, IDE. Schönes IDE. Und nicht vergessen, Leute, und nicht vergessen, die Jumper an den IDE-Drives richtig setzen.
Weil man will ja nicht etwa, dass das CD-Laufwerk die Festplatte blockiert.
Master-Slave-Cable-Select-Jumper. Ah, yes. Exzellent.
Guck da her.
Manche Hardware-Hersteller hatten auch ganz furchtbar abgedrehte Setups, dass du zwei Jumper machen konntest.
Da konntest du einen Jumper so machen und einen Jumper so. Und das hat dann irgendwie ganz spezielle Bedeutung gehabt.
Ja, genau. Da spricht der Experte eher.
Guck. Guck.
Ne, mir haben die nie gefallen, die ergonomischen Keyboards.
Iiih, du Wireless-Maus.
Wie alt bist du? Ich bin 35. Du hast ja gar keinen Plan, ja. Kann ich alles wissen.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch das zu geschrieben, dass du hast ja gar keinen Plan. Du Spaß.
Wo hat der Typ denn die neu verpackten Uralt-Bauteile her?
Naja, der hat gesagt, er hat ein Jahr gebraucht oder so, bis er alles zusammen bekommen hat. Und es sind ja auch nicht alle Teile original verpackt.
Er hat halt Teile mit Originalverpackung.
Wo ist das Handbuch mit aufgedrucktem Echtheitssiegel?
Wo ist das Echtheits-Zertifikat, Leute?
Ohne Echtheits-Zertifikat kann ich das Video nicht ruhigen Gewissens gucken.
Es gab was. Man hat doch gar keine Diskette mehr gebraucht.
Man konnte, also spätestens Windows ME konnte man von CD booten, wenn man den Rechner hatte, der das konnte.
Und ich bilde mir ein, Windows 98 konnte man auch von CD booten.
Wenn es das Board konnte.
Huge.
Jawoll.
Oh, das dauert. Ja, das dauert.
Oh, der Sound, Leute, müsst ihr euch mal den Sound anhören. Wie das CD-Laufwerk hochdreht.
Das gab es gar nicht. Das gibt es nicht mehr, weil ich habe noch nicht mal mein optisches Laufwerk im PC seit den letzten drei PCs.
Welche Ideen hat man damals verwendet? Boah.
Dings hier. Zwitter 19 hast du Visual Studio, was war das? Du hast Visual Studio 6, glaube ich, verwendet.
Mit Visual Basic. Das war damals angesagt.
Wie der Helikopter der abhebt.
Aber noch kein Sound.
Ja, mit. Na gut.
War ja eh schon fragwürdig, ob der Netzwerk-Driver überhaupt bei Windows dabei ist.
Das war. Deswegen war damals Computer installiert. Das war echt so eine Tagesaufgabe. Du hast erst mal einen halben Tag gebraucht, den ganzen Shit zusammenzubauen. Man heute ist alles on board.
Da gibt es nicht so viel mehr zu bauen. 30.000 Gadgets erst mal anschließen und dann fünf Stunden Treiber suchen, Treiber downloaden und Treiber installieren.
All right, now that all the basic stuff is installed and ready, it's time to add in some more parts.
Damals hat man dann noch die PC Welt, hat man dann noch eine GameStar oder eine PC Welt CD geholt und so was für aktuelle Treiber, weil man sich nicht runterladen wollte übers Modem.
Was für Milliarden Equipment hat der Typ?
Wo? Der Sound des Lüfters.
Die billigen Aktivboxen nehmen. Und das Flimmern beim Booten genau.
Das ist eine wireless Mause.
Gleich kommt gleich kommt der Login Sound, Leute. Der Login Sound.
Also irgendwann demnächst, wenn er mal gebootet hat, müsste der Login Sound kommen.
Excellent. Du du du du du du. Exzellent. Exquisite.
At this point, the computer is pretty much done.
But let's add a few more extra parts to complete the experience.
Game controllers, webcam, microphone and floppy disk holders.
Now the whole point of building a gaming computer is to play games.
Using Windows 98 for a gaming machine like this is popular for a reason.
Windows 98 at its core is still DOS.
What that means is they can play some of the first ever games released for PCs.
In addition to that, the powerful Voodoo 5 in there was able to hold its own for a while after its release.
So we're going to take a look at different games over a 20 year time span all running on the same computer.
Pock Graphics.
Das sind doch DOS Games. Gar so schlimm sah das nicht aus.
Oh SimCity. SimCity 2000. Richtig nice. Das habe ich damals auch sehr viel gespielt.
Diese Sounds.
Oh das habe ich, das habe ich gehasst das Game.
Das fanden damals alle geil, weil es so cool ausgesehen war und es pre-rendert hintergrund hat.
Ich fand das richtig schlecht. Mit diesem einzelnen Fotos durchklicken.
Richtig, ich habe das gehasst das Spiel.
Das erste Need for Speed.
Ab jetzt wird es langsam interessant.
Lego Island.
Wahnsinns Physics.
Das war auch nice.
Ah ja, das war ja eine ganze Serie damals von durch die Tunnel-Fleet-Games.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel.
Es ruckelt ein bisschen.
Ein wenig ruckelt.
Ist das ein Lüfter?
Wie viel Arbeit speichere ich? Ich glaube 512. Also richtig viel, richtig viel.
Es hat sich auch optisch einiges getan.
Ich meine, man erkennt, dass es ein Desktop-PC ist.
Aber wenn man sich heute mal Desktop-PCs anguckt, also allgemein Schreibtische anguckt, das sieht doch schon alles anders aus.
Heute hat alles RGB. Es ist vieles zumindest optisch deutlich hochwertiger in der Verarbeitung.
Der Bluetooth-Rant.
Wenn der Chat will, dass wir den Bluetooth-Rant gucken, gucken wir den Bluetooth-Rant.
Ja, aber mal langsam. Bluetooth ist schon ziemlich alt.
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Moment. Bluetooth ist auch nicht für wahnsinnige Range gedacht.
Dass es wenig Strom verbraucht.
Was hat er denn für Probleme, Alter? Selbst mit den neuen Bluetooth-Standards ist das gar nicht so schlecht.
BLE, das Low-Energy-Ding, ist super zum Übertragen von irgendwelchen Sensordaten.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau, was er hat.
Okay, da hat er recht. Bluetooth-Pairing ist tatsächlich unnötig kompliziert.
Vor allem warum regen sich die Amis gerade darüber auf, wenn sie ihre Pappdeckelwände haben?
Wir haben wenigstens richtige Wände und keine Holzwände.
Das ist ein typisches Beispiel von einem Standard, der einfach über die Jahre wild gewachsen ist.
Das ist tatsächlich für'n Arsch. Aber das Problem haben viele Dinge, die sich einfach über die Jahre entwickelt haben.
Ich mein, guckt euch den USB-Standard an, da blickt auch keine Sau mehr durch.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man sich so aufregt, das ist mir zu blöd.
Ich mein, Bluetooth ist sicherlich nicht fehlerfrei und hat wie alles seine Nachteile.
Aber mittlerweile ist das echt in Ordnung. Sogar Audio-Wiedergabe geht mittlerweile ganz gut über Bluetooth.
Das war ja früher, da hast du das Gefühl gehabt, du bist unter der Decke oder du bist in der Badewanne oder so.
Aber sogar mit den neueren Bluetooth-Versionen und halbwegs gutem Codec und alles, sogar Audio-Übertragung ist jetzt ganz gut.
Also ich muss sagen, Bluetooth ist eines der Sachen, wo ich mich noch relativ wenig darüber aufgeregt habe.
Ich verwende es aber auch nicht oft. Ich verwende es halt dann, wenn man es für die Fernbedienung zum Fernsehen verwendet.
Für das Abfragen meiner Pflanzensensoren im Hof zum Beispiel verwende ich Bluetooth.
Im Hof habe ich in ein paar Blumentöpfen und im Beet ein paar Flora-Sensors stehen.
Und die frage ich mit dem ESP32 ab nach dem aktuellen Stand und dafür funktioniert das wunderbar.
Na, man kann auch unsinnig renten.
Übrigens, eine coole Sache, die ich vorhin in einem Video gesehen habe, Aliexpress, also für alle, die mal mutig sein wollen.
Oder sich aber denken, bei Aliexpress gibt es jetzt Bluetooth, äh, nicht Bluetooth.
Ah, zu viel Bluetooth.
Also, das ist ein Gerät mit WLAN und da kann ich, das ist quasi ein Remote-Schalter für USB-Geräte.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Raspberry irgendwo stehen habe, die Dinger werden ja per USB angeschlossen.
Und das Ding ist nicht mehr erreichbar und ich will, dass der sich neu startet, dann geht das nicht, weil ich halt remote mein USB nicht schalten kann.
Und das stecke ich zwischen quasi die Steckdose und den Raspberry und dann kann ich den per WLAN ein- und ausschalten, den Raspberry.
Das ist quasi ein Sonoff, ein Sonoff für, oder ein Shelley für USB.
Finde ich eigentlich eine ganz coole Geschichte.
Ja, Neko Rock habe ich, das habe ich heute Morgen gesehen auf, äh, bei Andreas Spieß auf YouTube.
Ähm, eigentlich ist es eine coole Geschichte, zumal dann ESP62 drauf ist und man das auch mit Custom-Firma flashen kann.
Das heißt, man, ja, Voltage 3,5 bis 20 Ampere ist, äh, vor allem extreme high pressure.
Was auch immer, pressure ist in dem Fall nicht das richtige Wort.
Äh, aber es sind halt die Chinesen, ja.
Äh, dazu kommt, dass das, was, Voltage ist 3,5 Ampere, what?
Mit den, mit den Einheiten haben wir es auch nicht so genau.
Mit den Einheiten haben wir es auch nicht so genau.
Äh, egal, das sind die Chinesen, die, die, die nehmen es da nicht so eng, bei solchen Geschichten, ja.
Äh, äh, ja.
Mit den Einheiten haben wir es auch nicht so genau. Äh, egal, das sind die Chinesen, die, die, die nehmen es da nicht so eng, bei solchen Geschichten, ja.
Ähm, die denken, die denken sich einfach, ähm, was würde der Kram kosten eigentlich aktuell, ja.
20.04. kommt es angeblich an, wenn man erst mal so 10 Stück von bestellen, kostet das Ganze in den Einkaufswagen.
Oh nee, ich muss mich anmelden, aber nicht.
Naja, 5, auch 50 Euro, ganz schön, 53 Euro, ganz schön, teuer.
Ja, aber an sich ist es eine coole Sache, dass man seine USB-Geräte da mit Remote schalten kann.
Eigentlich, eigentlich cool, ja.
Und ich glaube, ich werde mir mal ein paar bestellen nachher.
Irgendwie, die werden dann erst mal eine Runde in Desinfektionsmittel gebadet, wenn die ankommen.
Corona Express.
Und dann probiere ich das mal aus.
Von der Idee her eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Geschichte.
Ach, hier haben sie es richtig.
Na, 20 Volt, das ist wahrscheinlich wegen Quick, Quick Charge und ähm, anderen Dingern.
Im Keller, im Keller bei mir, habe ich auch 12 Volt über USB am Controller dran.
Weil, kann ich erklären, weil, ähm, das Netzteil, was im Keller hängt, versorgt, quasi durch den Kabel, was in der Wand ist,
ein Tablet, also es hängt im Flur, es hängt im ersten Stock ein Tablet an der Wand und dem Erdgeschoss ein Tablet an der Wand.
Und das Netzteil dafür ist im Keller.
Und wenn ich das Netzteil auf 5 Volt stelle, dann, ähm, ist, ist, ist, der Spannungsabfall ist zu hoch, dass die Tablets noch ordentlich laden.
Durch die, durch die, irgendwie 20 Meter, 20 Meter Kabel, die sich da irgendwie rumschlängeln.
Das funktioniert da nicht richtig.
Also, die, die laden zwar, aber die laden saumäßig langsam.
Deswegen habe ich das Netzteil im Keller auf 12 Volt eingestellt und habe dann an den Tablet,
selber noch einen Konverter von 2, von 12 Volt auf, auf 5.
Und unten dran ist halt auch noch ein ESP866, der allerdings 12 Volt als Input verkraftet.
Also, manchmal ist es gar nicht, manchmal ist es gar nicht so schlecht, wenn der Kram mehr verkraftet.
Auch wenn, natürlich, USB normalerweise 5 Volt sind.
Xfeldle1337, neun Monate, huge sub.
Sixhead sub.
Huge sub. Sixhead sub.
Was macht das? Nur Strom ein- und ausschalten?
Äh, ob man da Daten drüber schleifen kann, bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Ich tippe mal eher auf ein.
Ich denke nicht, dass man da Daten durchschleifen kann.
Ich denke, man kann bloß ein- und ausschalten.
Wobei...
Das kann sogar sein, dass da Daten drüber gehen.
Äh...
Ja, keine Ahnung, ob da Daten drüber gehen.
Möglich!
Klar!
Gehen da auch da- So klar ist das nicht!
Ah, ist das nicht!
Ah, um USB mit Strom zu versorgen, musst du nicht- Ah, hier!
Vielleicht, okay, vielleicht gehen da auch wirklich Daten drüber.
Aber ich werd's mal ausprobieren.
Da kann man einfach eine smarte Steckdose benutzen.
Ja, kannst du. Da brauchst du eine smarte Steckdose.
Dort drinnen einen USB- äh, einen quasi normalen Stecker auf USB-Stecker
und dann dort das Gerät reinstecken.
Was aber, ähm, halt die ganze Steckdose blockiert.
Für mich ist es ganz praktisch.
Ich hab solche Steckdosen bei mir daheim.
Ähm, fuck, wie hießen die Dinger?
Ähm...
Die letzten hab ich bei Notebooks billiger gekauft.
Guck' ma mal, was war da. Hier, die da!
Äh, nee, nee. Aber- aber fast.
Aber fast, fast, fast.
Die da!
Die hab ich im Haus und da ist halt ganz praktisch.
ganz praktisch die haben halt einen ganz normalen stecker und ab unten noch zwei
usb anschlüsse und die man kann über wireless halt nur das hier schalten und
das hier unten nicht und dafür sind die sachen ganz praktisch im keller zum
beispiel im keller habe ich so der raspberry ist im keller unten hier an
einem usb dran und hier oben ist das letzte dran was halt tablets und
gedöns im flur mit strom versorgt so dass kann ich schalten den raspberry
selbst kann ich nicht schalten und hätte ich jetzt so ein ding so ein usb strom
schalte ding da könnte ich den raspberry auch einen ausschalten was
manchmal ganz praktisch ist weil manchmal schaffe ich trotzdem das ding
in irgendeiner art und weise wenn man wieder das wlan abgekackt ist oder so
dass es halt hängt und sich nicht verbindet da würde ich den gerne
neu starten ohne in keller gehen zu müssen also für so was ist es praktisch
und das habe ich an fast jeder steckdose die irgendwelche geräte hat die man
remote benutzen muss benutzt du so was wie ein broker ich
verwende nicht ein broker ich verwende das hier
ist aber was ähnliches ja haben alle unterschiedliche stärken ist aber auch
ist quasi so ein haumautomation hab wie ein broker ja war ich also davon werde
ich mir wahrscheinlich gleich mal ein paar bestellen habt ihr übrigens ist
euch mal auf github aufgefallen dass die sterne weg sind bei den repos ist
euch das mal aufgefallen die sterne bei den repos sind weg auf github wenn man
nicht eingeloggt ich weiß nicht wie es aussieht wenn man eingeloggt ist ich bin
hier bin ich eingeloggt aber wenn man flatter sucht in der suche selbst in der
suche selbst in die sterne noch da ich mein flatter ist eines der projekte mit
den meisten sterben hier sind die noch da
aber lustigerweise hier sind die sterne weg und ich hoffe das ist ein bug bei
github weil ich fände es sehr also um nicht zu sein extrem scheiße dass die
sterne standardmäßig nicht mehr eingezeigt angezeigt werden
folter kack warum das ist eines der wichtigsten sachen um sich mal so über
die beliebtheit eines projektes zu informieren wenn man das noch wenn man
das neu findet was es für sterne hat
also ich hoffe ich hoffe das ist nur temporär dass man das nicht sieht das
ist voll für den arsch dass das weg ist wirklich ziemlich ziemlich abkack
überlegt ob wir noch was gucken wollen weil ich krieg so langsam aber sicher irgendwie hunger
die bestkommen so ein game star video an die besten spiele gerade gerade
kostenlos gibt mit moris am start am aris geht immer der maurice
hallo liebe zuschauer mein name ist christian schneider und mein name ist
moris weber und wir wollen euch heute jeweils drei kostenlos spielbare titel
vorstellen die jetzt gerade für ein paar tage frei verfügbar sind und zu
denen wir persönlich auch einen bezug haben dass wir also ein bisschen
detaillierter ein bisschen die die games da ist auch im home office wie es aussieht
nach schaftlicher erzählen können warum wir euch diese spiele empfehlen würden
moris du fängst an ich denke der größte titel aktuell ist das ein greenscreen
das wäre ich fände das geil wenn es ein greenscreen ist und sich einfach ein
büro in den tag und gemacht hätte
gratis spielen kann ist assassins creed odyssey echt haben wir leider nicht
unbegrenzt gratis spielen also nicht abstauben wie ein paar von fritz
empfehlungen später man kann jetzt aber noch bis zum 23 märz gratis
reinschauen in das ding und das bringt mir nichts das ja nur noch ein tag
grad für die zeit wo man vielleicht auch länger jetzt zu hause hofft weil es
halt eine klassische ubisoft open world ist es eine gerade in der zeit von einem
spiel ich auch immer nur zu hause leute pp hands danach noch kauft aber man
kriegt es halt nicht dauerhaft geschenkt und ich persönlich mich hat bei dem
spiel bislang aber ich habe es noch nicht durchgespielt bislang man hat
immer gerade abgeschreckt dass es halt so groß ist aber gerade jetzt wo man viel
mehr zeit zum zocken hat weil netflix schon überlastet ist und die
aufführung runterschraubt und alles und man sich beschäftigungen sucht ist das
doch super und persönlich fand ich auch den schritt den assassins creed damit
gemacht wir sind meister im social distance nicht genau richtig hin zu mehr
rollenspiel hin zu mehr story das war genau das coole an der serie für mich
also genau das richtige schaut auf jeden fall gerne mal rein ich glaube gerade
wenn man sich davon überzeugen will ist jetzt der perfekte zeitpunkt ich mach
gleich weiter mit einer open world nochmal von ubisoft und zwar gibt es
gerade im epic store jetzt die ganze woche noch das open world action spiel
watchdogs 1 zum kostenlosen download wenn ihr krassen hackermans warte leute wir brauchen wir brauchen noch in in meinem
wir brauchen noch das hacker im ort das habe ich gar nicht drinne
hacker man
die gif wo ist das gif
ist das ist das gar kein gif
ich brauche ich will das gif
ja ja ja
noch das gif
Exzellent!
Hackermans
So
So ist gut perfekt. Jetzt haben wir auch hier unseren Hacker man am start
Immer also auch wenn diese woche vorbei ist
Könnte das weiterhin spielen und was ist ja durchaus ein, bisschen umstritten gewesen hat mir nicht gefallen
Grafik downgrade gab aber ich muss das grafik dauernd war mir wurscht mich hat es an sich nicht angesprochen aber ich habe es
Ich sag es auf genug ich bin kein großer open world fan
Trotz der hexer thematik
Toll finde es ist eher eine düstere spielwelt ist ja auch eher eine düstere geschichte
Gerade im kontrast zum gta was ja sehr bunt ist ist das chicago aus watchdogs nicht nur super detailliert mit fantastischen kleinen
details und kleinen
animationen also allein auf dem friedhof gibt es drei oder vier unterschiedliche trauer
animationen der mpc sie da hingehen also man kann wahnsinnig viel da entdecken
Es ist grundsätzlich auch einfach ein bisschen realistischer ein bisschen
Ja dadurch eben auch düsterer und es sieht auch für heutige verhältnisse immer noch fantastisch aus
gerade wenn man vielleicht jetzt sowas wie die worst mod mit drauf machen würde jetzt zuletzt gab es auch eine
experimentelle
Übrigens die eine der sache warum watchdogs downgraded wurde lag schlicht und ergreifend daran
Nicht, weil ubisoft gesagt hat leute wir wollen es unbedingt dauernden sondern weil die letzte konzolen generation so scheiße war
Hardware mäßig so so kompletter krepp bei release die mussten das dauen krähen
Die links dazu packen wir in die video beschreibung die heckermans also
Also das würde ich jedem empfehlen der vielleicht bislang gesagt hat ja watchdogs interessiert mich jetzt nicht so richtig
Und vor allen dingen wenn ihr das mal auf pc ausprobieren wollt dann das ist tatsächlich noch ein bisschen das problem an der geschichte
Dann habt ihr jetzt die gelegenheit eben kein geld ausgeben zu müssen um zu schauen ob es vielleicht bei euch
Rund oder eben doch nicht rund läuft denn das ist das große problem bei watchdogs es kann selbst mit moderner
Hardware passiert das ist nicht wirklich flüssig läuft gerade wenn man mit einem auto durch die stadt fährt also das so ein bisschen
Nachlade probleme streaming probleme drin sind weil sie hatten ihre technik
Hätten wir jetzt hätten wir jetzt die neue ps5 ssd mit 5,5 terabyte pro sekunde
Zum miss auf dem pc im griff das ist aber ein bisschen ein glücksspiel und es gibt auch ein paar
Foren wo man ein paar sachen ausprobieren kann ein paar sachen beschrieben werden das kommt sehr auf die hardware konfigurationen an
auch wenn man einen starken rechner hat kann man diese probleme haben wenn man etwas schwächeren rechner hat kann sein dass man die
Gar nicht hat und das läuft alles im butterweich und problemlos die mods wiederum war es nicht so war es nicht so dass sogar
Watchdogs und assassins creed im gleichen universum spielt die hatten doch anspielungen
in watchdogs auf assassins creed umgetreten
Ja maurice guckt so wie haltet sich will jetzt auch was sagen effekte wieder da die in der ursprünglichen demo mal gezeigt wurden zum
Beispiel dynamische schatten von den scheinwerfern und sowas alles und bringen auch so ein bisschen mehr wettereffekte rein aber selbst wenn man das alles nicht
mehr drauf machen
Chicago als innenstadt gebiet sondern auch die umliegenden gebiete es gibt hinten in der ecke so eine
etwas
nicht urbanere sondern eher so so so vorstadt oder so fast schon kleinstadt gegen die richtig richtig cool auch noch mal aussieht die geschichte
ist hat einen schlechten ruf ist aber finde ich
spannender als man als man erwarten würde ich richtige
hexa grill
den season pass dazu kaufen oder nicht der würde 20 euro kosten da ist jede menge drin vor allen Dingen ist ein
komplettes adorn drin wo man eine andere spielfigur spielt und auch noch mal viele viele stunden
story inhalte bekommt und es sind noch zusätzliche story missionen mit drin in dem season pass und
es wenn man diese 20 euro tatsächlich ausgeben will was man nicht unbedingt muss man kriegt auch so ein fettes paket wenn man aber doch
sagt ich kaufe mir den season pass dazu es ist vor allen Dingen ein
kostüm dabei was ich jedem empfehlen würde denn im gegensatz zu den normalen so kappy und
solchen sachen hat er da so ein so ein zwanzigerjahre schlapphut auf also so ein bisschen so mafia
Outfit und damit macht das spiel automatisch mal ein bisschen mehr schluss ist eher hier
mafioso mäßig
unterwegs ist und im gegensatz zu odyssey darf man ja auch einfach behalten wenn man sich jetzt bei epic holt
Epic store irgendwo muss ja der haken sein einfach ein gutes spiel abgestaubt aber ich persönlich also
weißt du gerade in zeiten wie diesen wenn ich mich in eine welt flüchten will dann ist das bestimmt nicht irgendein düsteres chicago wo ich mir
Friedhof animationen
da gibt es nur eine und das ist mittelerde natürlich die beste eskapismus welt von allen
und auch in die kann man sich jetzt beste eskapismus welt
in die games da immer ist komplett gratis bis zum 30. april mit allen abenteuern und geschichten
das heißt man kann das komplett erleben gerade ohne probleme übrigens auch das andere spiel der entwickler dungeon der dragons online
aber herr der ringe online ist für mich was herr der ringe online das gibt es noch als alles andere auf der welt
objektiver fakt
das gibt es noch das ist das ist das game ist
15 jahre alt oder so das mittelerde dass man so toll findet und es sieht auch dementsprechend aus
drauf geschaut dass halt ein gandalf jetzt zum beispiel nicht
komplett absurd neu aussieht und sie haben sich halt auch sachen ausgedacht da bin ich immer nicht so ein fan davon
wie diese angmar geschichte mit dem hexenkönig am anfang
was immer so die die zuflucht aller entwickler eigentlich ist wenn sie herr der ringe spiele machen und sich irgendwas ausdenken wollen
dann fallen sie immer auf ja der hexenkönig hatte doch da irgendwo im norden noch mal ein reich da machen wir doch noch irgendwas cooles mit
hat der krieg im norden zum beispiel aufgemacht aber nicht desto trotz ein cooles online rollenspiel mit einer fantastischen welt
schraubt amazon nicht an einem herr der ringe mmo ne ne
amazon schraubt an eine herr der ringe serie und amazon bringt ein mmo raus aber beides hat nichts miteinander zu tun
das mmo was
was amazon raus bringt ist das hier
da startet jetzt auch demnächst die beta
und das wollte ich mir mal angucken vielleicht mit dem friseur zusammen wenn ich den überredet bekomme das ist das mmo von amazon
von sorry sorry leute von von amazon müssen ja müssen da korrekt sein
ne da war ich mit 15 jahre alt doch gar nicht so verkehrt von 2007 ist
eigentlich dass man sich jetzt
offener denn je einfach mal anschauen kann wenn man eh nichts anderes zu tun hat der friseur spielt gerade kein bdo mehr da spielt
irgendwelche komischen mobile games zu hocken und spiele zu zocken also da sind tatsächlich jetzt alle
dlc ist mit dabei
genau ok ja sehr cooles angebot
wenn ihr deutlich deutlich deutlich deutlich weniger zeit zur führung habt
dann ist meine nächste empfehlung vielleicht passend für euch sie gibt es auch im epic store
das andere spiel dieser woche ist das denn die ja das ist denn die
ein das kann das kann ich echt empfehlen das ist wirklich sehr kurz mal
da brauchst du keine ahnung in in der stunde in der stunde bist du dreimal durchgelaufen durch gerannt ja
das lohnt sich aber
die vielleicht auf den ersten blick ein bisschen
verschreckend wirken kann weil sie ein bisschen schwer zu erklären ist und sowas ist immer ein bisschen
ein bisschen abschreckend finde ich weil man nicht so richtig weiß worauf soll man sich da eigentlich das aber ist echt empfehlenswert
unfassbar überraschendes
sympathisches leicht zugängliches spiele erlebnis und erzählt erlebnis in dem man
am anfang einen einfachen büro mit arbeiters spielt der sich aus seinem büro
der aus seinem büro rausgeht und dann verschiedene wege durch so eine büroanlage gehen kann
und dem im fall auch für dieser verschiedenen wege die verrücktesten sachen passieren
kommentiert von einem oft sprecher der auch immer wieder die vierte wand durchbricht und mit dem spieler selbst auch immer mal
spricht und
es gibt auch eine es gibt auch eine demo auf steam zum beispiel also wenn ihr gar nicht jetzt sagt ok epic store will ich
mir gar nicht installieren es gibt auch eine demo auf steam zum download die ist auch noch mal eine eigene geschichte
und vor allen dingen braucht einfach insgesamt für das ganze spiel nicht allzu viel zeit also nach ein paar stunden habt ihr da alles
gesehen das aber wirklich toll ist und deshalb bin ich ein großer fan von dem spiel es ist
absolut nichts davon ist in irgendeiner weise zeitverschwendung
bin ein bisschen skeptisch bei so offen ist also bei manchen auf mordspielen da sind ja viele aufgaben drin wo ich so denke
hey ihr habt kein respekt vor meiner vor meiner lebenszeit mehr oder weniger und gibt mir nicht permanent das beste was ich haben könnte
stanley parable gibt euch in jeder sekunde das beste was was es zu erleben gibt und es ist einfach auch schweine lustig
also das kann ich euch ja auch empfehlen man kann man spielt das spiel in einer stunde zwei drei mal durch wobei durchspielen
halt nicht wirklich
du siehst du gehst von anfang bis ende und es gibt halt zig verschiedene wege
ich glaube es gibt irgendwie acht oder neun verschiedene enden
und das lohnt sich auf jeden fall da braucht man nicht brauchen wirklich nicht viel zeit für und das lohnt sich
oder mehr ich weiß es gibt auf jeden fall einige
verkopfter kritikerlieblingen wo die sich dann irgendwie
dann irgendwelche leute da auf die ssg gibt es eigentlich so viele hälter wenn es um den epik store geht ganz ehrlich gesagt ich hätte auch immer den epik store
aber ich weiß gar nicht so genau warum
wahrscheinlich weil man den epik store gut halten kann
und es gibt wirklich solche spiele ist es meiner meinung nach nicht das ist auch einfach spaß und
deshalb zieht es ja kommen wir kommen zum punkt
für konsolen und dann wird es auch noch ein pc patch geben weil da kommt noch mal eine
ultimate edition mehr oder weniger
kontent das wird noch ein bisschen dauern ist jetzt gerade für den sommer angekündigt mal sehen ob es dabei bleibt aber jetzt könnte das spiel erst mal
spielen und wenn ihr jetzt vielleicht sagen wir nur einen abendzeit habt dann wird das ein unglaublich befriedigender abend so viel
gebe ich euch hand und siehe drauf
aber was für einen klappen
hand und siegel oder
griff und griff und
Hand und siegel
Hand und siegel ja dann also da für hand und siegel würde ich ja alles abkaufen tritts vor allem wenn es geschenkt ist
aber was für einen klappen text es gibt hier in jeder sekunde das beste was du haben kannst
macht mal weiter
immer ein bisschen schade findet das tun sie halt nicht immer diese open world spiele
ein anderes spiel dass das auch nicht immer tut aber doch ziemlich oft ist
beste
bekommen und bekommen ständig große erweiterungen
ist auch so ein spiel wiederum das gegenteil von standy parable das ist jetzt nichts was du sagen kannst ich spiele das mal eben zwischendurch
dann spielst du eher die apple 3 einfach mal ein bisschen lässig monstermetzeln ist ein spiel das wirklich nur dann richtig geil ist und
sagst ok ich habe richtig viel zeit ich konzentriere mich jetzt auf dieses spiel
ja also bis man ich blicke ich blicke obwohl ich jetzt da schon ein bisschen zeit reingesteckt hat also bis man alles gecheckt hat in
pass of exile das ist eine lebensaufgabe
nach solchen spielen suchen die leute ja vielleicht gerad und dann ist das extra fantastisch weil es hat
einen lächerlichen skilltree so aufgeblasen so viele möglichkeiten ist riesig auch was die was die was die story angeht
zehn akte lang und dann hast du noch die story ist aber schlecht
wirklich eines der schlechtesten kampagnen die ich kenne
die ist wirklich mies
darüber nachdenken richtig in mechanik ja da hat er recht
da hat er recht ja gerade jetzt eben wieder ein blick jetzt ist ja gerade die neue liga gestartet das bietet sich sogar
kurze nachfrage zu pass of exile weil ich durchaus immer lust auf diese genre habe aber ich manchmal ein bisschen
abschrecken lasse von so ab grasen elementen in dieser art von spielen
ist das eher gradlinig also kann ich da auch einfach sagen ich würde gerne einfach mal gradlinig die story
durch spielen um mal so ein bisschen die abwechslung zu sehen oder ist da auch viel so ähnlich wie bei den
overwäten von diablo dass man die karte mehr oder weniger nach items so abscannt wie als wäre man so ein
leser drucker
ja so hat hat schon auch ein bisschen es hat aber du kannst schon relativ gerade durch die story durchgehen
die story ist auch nicht schwierig also die story durch die story durch kriegt man eigentlich
immer irgendwer aber die story ist sagt halt
die gebiete sind vergleichsweise überschaubar es gibt so ein paar wo du mal bisschen irgendwie weiter erkunden musst aber
wenn du auch jetzt irgendwie dann nicht bock hast danach noch irgendwie ewig ins endgame zu gehen einfach sagst du willst mal eine story durchspielen
die ist nicht der hammer die story von part of exile aber die ist schon cool führt sich durch abwechslungsreiche gebiete hat coole bosse und sowas
da kann man auch einfach mal einfach mit einem mal durchspielen spaß haben und das sind wie gesagt auch schon zehn akte da kannst du einige zeit reinstecken
und was für part of exile gilt gilt auch für meine nächste empfehlung es sind beides sehr faire free to play spiele also da sind keinerlei pay to win elemente drin sowohl im part of exile nicht als auch in meiner nächsten und letzten großen empfehlung nämlich
das stimmt das stimmt also man muss sagen pay to win elemente in dem sinn gibt es ja nicht es gibt ja ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob es im part of exile doch ich glaube es gibt pvp aber juckt kein mensch
gerade weil es halt nicht so pvp fokussiert ist ist es mit pay to win nicht so weit her und es gibt halt auch nichts es gibt eigentlich skins und das einzige was man halt braucht ist und das ist halt das was part of exile im endeffekt kostet wenn man es wirklich
halt ernsthaft spielen will man braucht ein bisschen mehr loot kisten also die stash erweiterung standardmäßig weiß ich gar nicht wie viele loot tabs man hat ich sag jetzt einfach mal zehn ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht damit kommt man für die kampagne vielleicht
vier also ein paar stash tabs muss man sich kaufen da kommt man nicht drumherum man kann erstmal anfangen man kann wahrscheinlich auch mit vier stash tabs die story halbwegs durchspielen wenn man es drauf anlegt aber später will man dann auf jeden fall mehr stashs haben aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so als würde es die welt kosten und part of exile ist eines der spiele wo ich tatsächlich gerne was für die für die transactions habe
die transactions da bezahlt habe
verfügbar ist es keine epic store werbung aber es ist jetzt einfach zufällig diese woche
ja ja hand und siegel drauf dass es keine epic werbung ist
ist einfach zufällig diese woche und zwar ist das the cycle vom berliner jager mit denen hatten wir letztens bei uns auf dem game tube kanal ein stream
was es kostet pass of exiles stash tabs kommt keine ahnung drei euro oder so ich muss gestehen ich hatte es vorher nur mal ganz ganz früh
kannst du kaufst du einfach ein paar packs dann kriegst du dann kriegst du dann irgendwie das ist nicht es ist nicht so teuer du kannst den pass of exile richtig viel geld ausgeben ich glaube die teuerste micro transaction pass of exile ist tausend es kann sein ich müsste erzählen aber ich glaube tausend euro
und da darfst du einen item design was sind was ins spiel reinkommt was das finde ich eigentlich eine ganz coole geschichte oder 800 ich glaube tausend oder gab es nicht tausend euro wo du dann ein item design darfst in der pre alpha phase gespielt bevor es tatsächlich startet ist jetzt in early access ist kostenlos runterladbar ist aber schon in season 2
und hatte es dann gar nicht groß auf dem schirm habe es für diesen stream habe ich da ein bisschen warm gespielt und seitdem spiele ich es immer wieder ganz gerne denn es ist ein wirklich sehr sehr guter shooter ob man ihn nun alleine spielt
ich habe davon noch nie was gehört von diesem game mir gefällt der grafik steel auch überhaupt nicht absolut keinen großen bock auf sowas wie bettel royale habe es hat bettel royale elemente man kann das aber auch sehr sehr gut spielen wenn man einen pve fokus verfolgen will denn das cool an diesem spiel ist man ist 20 minuten lang mit 20 anderen spielern auf einen außerirdischen planeten geworfen und muss dort ressourcen sammeln monster bekämpfen und am ende kommt ein landungsschiff und man springt in das landungsschiff rein und wird
gerettet man kann aber zwischendurch eben auch andere sammler also andere menschliche spieler angreifen man kann sich aber auch mit ihnen verbünden ihn dann aber auch wieder an den rücken fallen und am ende geht es darum wer die meisten ressourcen in dieser runde gewonnen hat nicht unbedingt wer die meisten kills gemacht hat man kann das wie gesagt entweder alleine spielen oder in gruppen von zwei oder vier leuten es sieht sehr schön aus es spielt sich ich weiß irgendwie gefällt mir der grafik steel nicht für das shooter kern gameplay und was mir am meisten gefällt
bei den spieler gerade im vergleich zu den meisten bettel royale spiele gerade sowas wie den PUBG es hat keinerlei downtime also man ist ständig hat man was zu tun also man hat nie dieses von dem ich sitze mal irgendwo auf der lauer und warte jetzt mal was um mich herum passiert oder warte bis die ersten 50 leute sich gegenseitig umgebracht haben nur damit ich irgendwo im ranking halbwegs oben stehe du hast die ganze zeit zu tun weil du die ganze zeit so kämpfe mit den mit den mit den tieren auf diesem planeten hast oder weil du irgendwie kleine
minimissionen machst es gibt teilweise auch kleinere story aufträge das aber nicht weiter will und dadurch merkst du gar nicht wie diese 20 ok dann ist es so eine mischung aus
minecraft bettel royale und gta ich habe keinen bock vor auf weitere early access games
2 große karten also 2 große welten und aktuell bauen sie gerade so eine raumstation die so ein bisschen ein hub werden soll macht wirklich für zwischendurch mal irgendwie abends zwei drei runden spielen total spaß
ja wunderbar und dann ergänzenden kleineren empfehlungen eine von jedem von uns jetzt hast du schon so viel werbung für den epic store gemacht fritz dann kann ich ja auch noch ein bisschen eigenwerbung einstreuen denn auf gamestar plus haben wir auch immer gratis spiele mit dem abo eben und das ist dieses mal
das mir besonders am herz ist tyronny tyronny die ich je gespielt habe weil du im grunde saurons polizeibeamten spielst was ein cooles setting für ein spiel ist du spielst halt nicht irgendwie den nobelen helden du spielst den agenten des dunklen herrschers das hat ich mir irgendwann mal auf steam geholt und nie gespielt um für frieden zu sorgen mit all den moralischen komplikationen die sich daraus vielleicht ergeben mögen ist kein perfektes spiel gerade gegen ende merkt man
okay da ist ihnen wahrscheinlich ein bisschen das budget ausgegangen hat mich aber fasziniert wie selten ein apg und gamestar plus ist auch sonst toll da gibt es nicht von uns beiden auch sehr viel mit dir fritz gibt es viele games tv folgen mit mir gibt es viele podcast also schaut doch vielleicht mal rein wenn ihr bock auf genau ich habe das mehr oder weniger durchgespielt an einem wochenende weil es mich so gefesselt hat du merkst das gegen ende halt auch du denkst okay zehn stunden mehr werden vielleicht noch angenehm tatsächlich also vielleicht auch statt die entwicklern messe dieses böse alien kleinen
alle autos in der stadt sind zu groß von sowohl von den verhältnissen zur straße und anderen objekten als auch zur verhältnis zum verhältnis zu jill also der hauptspielfigur die ist laut wikipedia eintrag von ihr entweder 172 oder 186 68 groß ja die autos sind echt riesengroß
die größe angeht in der welt dürfte sie nur so 145 bis 150 groß sein steht schon ein bisschen kaputt aus nicht stimmen falsch aber es gibt ja gut was auch immer hätte nie drauf geachtet so heute sind wir wach ich würde schon sagen dass wir wach
sind drei stunden am start gewesen ich gucke mal wer am start ist den ich hausen kann gibt es irgendjemand
jemals
na ja
jene da
Keiner das brauchen würde
Der lost ich würde lost haus aber lost der brauchst nicht der hat der hat schon massig massig
Zuschauer immer würde gern jemand hausen der der das gebrauchen kann
Ja zumindest Keiner da von denen die in den ich gerade follow
Leute macht's gut ich geh jetzt was futtern erst mal gehe ich aufs Klo dann gehe ich was futtern
Oh schnell noch mal fragen habe ich fragen was oh fuck da haben wir für nächstes mal haben wir was am start
Also wir sehen uns das nächste mal macht's gut bis denn zu